monsieur le Président de la Commission
du développement durable cher Jean-Marc
mes chers collègues nous recevons ce
matin pour une table ronde sur les
transports de voyageurs pendant les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de Paris
2024 monsieur Florent Bardon
coordonnateur national des mobilité pour
les Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
Paris 2024 auprès du directeur général
des infrastructures des transports et
des
mobilités madame Laurence de brinca
directrice d'étude études et Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques d'île-france
mobilité monsieur Edgar directeur
délégué aux Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de la RATP et Monsieur
Frédéric dupoui directeur du département
influence territoire et
international monsieur Jonathan Durieux
directeur adjoint du programme Jeux
Olympiques et paralympique Paris 2024 de
la SNCF et Madame Sandrine Gourlet
directrice des relations extérieures de
la Société du Grand Paris et Monsieur
Denise boy Directeur Délégué aux
Relations
parlementaires nous souhaitons vous
entendre sur la question des transports
pendant les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques mais la Coupe du monde de
rugby venant de se terminer c'est
également l'occasion de dresser un
premier bilan de la gestion des flux
autour de cet événement qui constituait
la dernière manifestation sportive
majeure accueillie en France avant les
jop la réussite de l'accueil des jeux en
France va en partie être jugée sur notre
capacité à assurer le transport de
l'ensemble des personnes concernées
athlètes et leur équipe journalistes
spectateurs personnel impliqués mais
aussi usagers habituels de plus au
moment de la présentation de sa
candidature la ville de Paris a pris des
engagements forts en la matière les
sites de compétition doivent être
entièrement accessibles en transport en
commun y compris pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite et les modes de
transport proposés doivent être propres
et respecter l'environnement or nous le
savons et le constatons dans tous nos
déplacements quotidiens les transports
franciliens rencontrent aujourd'hui des
difficultés à cela s'ajoutent les
retards prix sur certains chantiers qui
empêcheront la livraison dans les temps
d'une partie des projet annoncé pour les
jeux le choix a été fait de se de se
concentrer sur les chantiers principaux
et tout est mise en œuvre afin qu'il
soit achevé le jour J comme vous le
savez notre commission suit
attentivement l'organisation des Jeux en
particulier à travers un groupe de
travail co-présidé par belkir badad et
Maxime minot qui vous ont d'ailleurs
entendu en février dernier et nous
sommes maintenant à 254 jours des JO et
287 des jop pour pourriez-vous nous en
faire un point sur l'avancement des
différents chantiers et la Cour des
comptes dans son rapport complémentaire
sur la préparation des Jeux Olympiques
et paralympique de Paris 2024 publié en
juillet dernier faisait notamment trois
recommandations vous concernant
pourriez-vous revenir sur l'état
d'avancement des différents plans
qu'elle évoquait et la prise en compte
des risques et des situations de
perturbation qui pourrai se produire et
maintenant je cède la parole au
président de la commission du
développement durable et de
l'aménagement du territoire qui est à
l'origine de l'organisation de cette
table ronde conjointe et je l'en
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente merci d'avoir accepté cette
cette proposition d'audition conjointe
mes chers collègues mesdames et
messieurs à mon tour de vous remercier
d'avoir accepté de participer à cette
audition conjointe qui nous permet de
réunir la commission des affaires
culturelles et de l'éducation et la
commission du développement durable et
de l'aménagement du territoire sur un
sujet d'intérêt commun les transports de
voyageurs pendant les jeux les Jeux
Olympiques et paralympique de Paris
2024 c'est une échéance importante non
seulement parce qu'elle permettra à la
France d'accueillir les meilleurs
athlètes venus de tous les continents
mais aussi parce qu'ell constitue pour
notre pays une occasion exceptionnelle
de rayonner et d'accueillir un public
que nous espérons nombreux c'est aussi
un défi aux multiples facettes en terme
d'organisation en terme logistique et
bien évidemment pour nos services de
transport nous sommes donc
particulièrement intéressés par ce que
vous pourrez nous dire mesdames et
messieurs sur la préparation de cet
événement majeur vous le savez nous
serons regardés dans le monde entier
l'ampleur des flux de personne sera
exceptionnel 25 sites devront être
desservis pour 50 sessions par jour à
yant jusqu'à 500000 spectateurs par jour
pour les seuls jeux olympiques les flux
seront également très importants pendant
les Jeux
paralympiques vous représentez ici
Mesdames et Messieurs les principales
organisations impliquées l'État avec la
djitm l'autorité organisatrice des
transports avec
île-de-fance mobilité les opérateurs de
transport avec la RATP la SNCF et la
Société du Grand Paris
potentiellement je l'espère très
prochainement à la Société des grands
projets j'identifie plusieurs enjeux
complémentaires de ceux évoqué par la
présidente Isabelle rochche au regard de
l'ambition que 100 % des spectateurs
puissent rejoindre les sites en
transport en commun en premier lieu
l'adaptation du plan de transport pour
permettre d'absorber les flux de
spectateurs sans dégrader le service
pour l'ensemble de la population
franilienne quelles organisations
envisagez-vous tant sur le plan des
ressources humaines que du matériel de
transport sachant que certaines lignes
seront particulièrement sollicité et
puis bien sûr je pense à l'enjeu de
l'information des voyageurs qui sera
essentiel pour assurer la fluidité que
que prévoyez-vous en la matière des
dispositions particulières peuvent être
être envisagées en matière de billétique
et notamment pour favoriser
l'intermodalité je ne serai pas plus
long dans mon mon propos et je laisse
donc madame la Présidente pour donner la
parole aux intervenants merci monsieur
le Président donc en effet maintenant
nos invités ont la parole pour 10
minutes en fait chaque entité
représentée dispose de de 10 minutes et
puis ensuite les orateurs de groupe vous
poseront des questions et vous pourrez y
répondre donc je reprends l'ordre que
j'ai énoncé tout au au départ donc en
commençant par Monsieur Florent
Bardon merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les
Députés je vous remercie de nous donner
l'opportunité de nous exprimer devant
vous effectivement on avait eu des
échanges les mois derniers avec certains
d'entre vous c'est l'occasion de de
faire le point à 254 jours de la
cérémonie d'ouverture comme vous l'avez
indiqué les depuis les les travaux de
préparation des transports pour les les
Jeux olympiques sont passés pleinement
dans une phase très opérationnelle
notamment depuis éé avec l'organisation
de compétition test ou de test events
selon la la terminologie de Paris 2024
et puis bien sûr l'événement majeur qu'
a constitué la la Coupe du monde de
rugby ce qui nous a donné l'occasion de
d'observer et
d'apprendre de tester un certain nombre
de choses en vue de de l'année prochaine
même si par exemple pour la Coupe du
monde de rugby c'est un événement qui
est sans commune mesure avec la
dimension des Jeux Olympiques pour
situer les choses la Coupe du monde de
rugby c'est 48 matchs sur 51 jours et
les Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
enfin pour les Jeux Olympiques en tout
cas c'est plus de 750 sessions sur 17
jours donc on voit bien que le défi n
n'est pas le même pour autant nous avons
évidemment à apprendre de ces événements
qui qui nous permettent de nous préparer
la Coupe du monde de rugby dans les
grandes lignes c'est c'est bien passé du
point de vue des transports mais on
pourra y revenir au fur et à mesure des
des questions que nous serons amenés à
examiner donc le défi pour nous c'est de
de concrétiser maintenant
de répondre aux besoins d'accueil
évidemment des des spectateurs des des
accrédités mais aussi et vous l'avez dit
tous les deux dans votre propos
introductif des des citoyens des des des
franciliens et des autres habitants pour
leur besoins du quotidien et les efforts
principaux portent d'abord et avant tout
sur la stabilisation des plans de
transport je pense que de France
mobilité aura l'occasion d'y revenir
très largement avec des cas plus épineux
plus épineux que d'autres sur lesquels
nous travaillons encore par exemple sur
la desserte de Paris West qui a le
euh la caractéristique d'accueillir à la
fois des compétitions sur le site de
Roland Garos c'est sur le site du Parc
des Princes donc qui constitue un un
défi en terme de desserte évidemment la
cérémonie d'ouverture le marathon pour
tous qui sont des des événements un
petit peu particuliers au sein des au
sein des des différentes compétitions
des Jeux Olympiques c'est un travail
énorme
euh nous sommes dans bonne voie de
finalisation de l'ensemble de ces plans
de transport et nous travaillons
également île- de-fance mobilité
évidemment en particulier avec la SNCF
et la RATP sur le plan de transport des
Jeux paralympiques euh le deuxè le
deuxième défi sur lequel nous sommes
très vigilants c'est la livraison des
grandes infrastructures de transport qui
sont en cours et qui sont attendu
l'ensemble des des calendriers sont tenu
et et confirmés même si les marges sont
sont faibles nous avons un suivi très
très régulier très précis de ces
chantier euh d'abord peut-être le
premier d'entre eux c'est le
prolongement de la ligne 14 auord à
Saint niipleel au sud jusqu'à
Orly le prolongement du rere EOL dont
une première rame a circulé du nouveau
matériel roulant en tout cas à circuler
lundi euh le réaménagement d'une en tout
cas le première tranche de du
réaménagement de la Gare du Nord et puis
le franchissement urbain de playel qui
permettra une correspondance entre la
ligne 14 et
euh le cheminement vers le vers le Stade
de France toujours au titre des
infrastructures un autre point sur
lequel nous sommes extrêmement vigilants
c'est l'ambition cyclable des Jeux
Olympiques avec la la création et la
réalisation d'un d'un réseau cyclable
pour l'Île-de-France continu entre la
ville centre Paris et les différents
sites de compétition donc ce sont 415 km
de piste cyclbl qui sont en cours
d'achèvement pour la majeure partie pour
des avec des aménagements pérennes pour
une plus petite part des aménagement
provisoire et donc là aussi nous avons
un suivi très régulier des mises en
chantier et des réalisations
engranger au fur et à mesure qu'on se
rapproche des Jeux
Olympiques associé au au linéaire
cyclable en tant que tel nous portons
aussi une politique très volontariste en
terme de stationnement cyclable parce
que c'est bien beau de pouvoir pédaler
jusqu'au site olympique faut ensuite
pouvoir garer son vélo et à ce titre
Paris 2024 porte pour l'ensemble des
partenaires des jeux un marché de
stationnement provisoire à l'approche
des des sites de compétition et enfin
évidemment ce sont les flottes de vélo
en libre service qui sont également euh
dans le viseur pour être augmenté à
l'occasion des Jeux Olympiques VLI d'un
côté les opérateurs de Free floating en
français dans le texte d'un autre
côté l'autre question de d'actualité et
dont dont vous aurez très prochainement
le la vision ce sont le la finalisation
des périmètres de circulation aux abords
des sites olympique et paralympique que
la la préfecture de police est en train
de de finaliser avec une période de
consultation qui va s'ouvrir ici la fin
de l'année euh
pour expliquer quels sont les les
différents périmètres de protection aux
abords des sites et au fur et à mesure
qu'on se rapproche les différentes
restrictions qui vont s'appliquer pour
sécuriser les sites et les modalités
d'accès évidemment pour les ayant droit
dans ces dans ces différentes zones dans
la foulée de cette phase de consultation
nous
ouvrirons une phase de communication et
d'information du grand public avec ce
qu'on est convenu d'appeler le Travel
dem management management ou la gestion
de la demande de transport ça consiste
euh à informer très largement à relayer
dans une campagne de communication très
euh très exhaustive l'ensemble de des
informations à disposition en amont des
Jeux Olympiques c'est à destination euh
du grand public et des professionnels
euh pour qu'ils puissent se préparer à
l'impact des jeux sur leur déplacement
du quotidien et anticiper le plus
possible leur déplacement euh en leur
demandant euh dans la mesure du possible
de réfléchir à diminuer certains
certains déplacements ou à changer de de
mode de déplacement d'horaire ou
d'itinéraire pour tenir compte euh des
impacts des Jeux Olympiques donc nous
lancerons cette cette campagne début
2024 à l'issue de cette période de
consultation de la préfecture de police
avec un site internet qui centralisera
cette cette information vous l'avez
mentionné également le travail sur
l'information voyageur en particulier
sur l'information voyageur numérique est
aussi au cours des au cœur pardon des
des travaux actuels île- de France
mobilité reviendra peut-être avec le
développement de d'une application
dédiée pour le l'information voyageur
des spectateurs en partenariat avec
Paris 2024 donc ça sera vraiment
l'application officielle euh pour les
les déplacements Jio et Jeux
paralympiques et l'autre l'autre
chantier on va dire en en cohérence avec
avec ce chantier spécifique d'une
application des jeux c'est la mise en
cohérence de l'ensemble des autres
dispositifs existants des acteurs du mar
chch sur le sur l'information voyageur
numérique pour être certain que chacun
délivre la même information et que les
spectateurs sont guidés de manière
cohérente entre les différents outils on
sait bien que tout le monde n'aura pas
dans sa poche l'application officielle
les outils existants Contin continueront
évidemment de délivrer de l'information
voyageur en lien avec ça c'est aussi la
préparation des différents dispositifs
de volontariat sur le terrain donc là
c'est des dispositifs humains
chaque partie prenante est en train de
recruter son volant de de volontaire
avec des des dispositions différentes et
ensuite dans le le le 1er et le 2è
trimestre 2024 ce sera le temps de la la
formation de ces agents volontaires ou
de ces de ces bénévoles selon les les
modalités pour accueillir et guider les
spectateurs vous l'avez évoqué également
nous avons énormément d'enjeux autour de
l'accessibilité pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite il y a un certain
nombre de mesures qui ont été et un plan
d'action qui a été annoncé but septembre
à l'occasion du comité interministériel
au handicap avec des mesures très
précises qui concernent chacun des des
opérateurs euh et aussi l'état pour
avancer sur les différents chantiers
donc c'est un un suivi précis que nous
réalisons également pour ce qui concerne
l'état en particulier nous avons il y a
un peu plus d'un an maintenant lancé un
plan de mise en accessibilité de la
flotte de taxi euh qui est en en très
bonne voie à la fois sur le la
délivrance des des licences et sur la
commande des véhicules adaptés je
pourrais revenir également au cours des
échanges par ailleurs il y a la
préparation des aéroports à l'accueil
des touristes évidemment mais aussi d'un
grand nombre d'accrédités puisque la
plupart des des délégations étrangères
vont arriver par la voie aérienne donc
c'est une période de très forte
sollicitation à laquelle en particulier
Aéroport de Paris se prépare avec des
enjeux très forts sur euh les bagages
qui sont souvent spécifique hors format
et donc avec une gestion de ces flux
logistiques adapté à ce public
particulier et également au départ
ensuite des délégations des modalités
d'enregistrement des portés au village
olympique qu'il convient de finaliser et
enfin mais
évidemment ce n'est pas le moindre la
moindre des choses euh nous débutons des
exercices de crise des exercices qui
nous permettent de T tester nos
dispositifs de chaîne de commandement
d'éprouver les les modalités que nous
avons que nous avons prévu et de
préparer des des plans B et ça c'est
évidemment le travail qui est qui est
devant nous au-delà des des Test Event
en tant que tel on va lors d'exercice
théorique à la fois mené par Paris 2024
et mené par par l'État par
ailleurs éprouver éprouver ces
dispositifs et les adapter avant avant
les Jeux pour se préparer pour mettre en
musique t C différents dossiers la
gouvernance qui avait été décidée à
l'automne dernier par le ministre des
Transports Clément bonne tourne à plein
régime nous avons réuni hier le 8e
comité stratégique des des
mobilités qui rassemble sous sa
présidence et en présence de la ministre
des Sports et des Jeux Olympiques
l'ensemble des acteurs des transports et
cela évidemment sans compter entre les
comités les très nombreux groupes de
travail qui nous permettent de converger
collectivement avec les collègues ici
présents sur l'ensemble de ces sujets
voilà je vous remercie et je me tiens
naturellement à votre disposition pour
répondre à toutes vos questions merci
beaucoup je donne la parole maintenant à
Madame Laurence de
brinca merci madame la Présidente alors
effectivement île-de-fance mobilité est
engagé maintenant de de longues dates
dans dans cette préparation des des Jeux
olympiques et
paralympiques puisque nous avions
accompagné Paris 2024 le comité
d'organisation des Jeux Olympiques dès
la phase de candidature et que nous
travaillons maintenant de depuis 2020
sur les les plans de transport et
l'ensemble des dispositions qui seront
mises en œuvre pendant les Jeux c'est la
mobilisation de plusieurs dizaines
d'agences qui à l'échelle d'î de France
mobilité est extrêmement importante qui
permet d'avancer donc nous nous sommes
effectivement maintenant dans une phase
qui est
opérationnelle la plupart des des plans
de de transport étant déjà
stabilisé nous travaillons notamment
dans le cadre des groupes de travail qui
sont pilotés par les préfectures de
département sur bah maintenant vraiment
le le le peaufinage du détail le pratico
pratique de du positionnement de la
barrière à l'horaire exact de de départ
de de certains services nous travaillons
dans ce cadre de 100 % des spectateurs
qui viennent en transport en commun ou
par les modes actifs que nous avons en
tout cas pris pour pour le compte
d'île-defance mobilité comme on se met
en capacité effectivement de transporter
quand même 100 % en transport en commun
le vélo évidemment nous nous allons le
promouvoir mais il y a potentiellement
des des aléas météorologiques qui
pourraient conduire sur certaines
sessions à ce que finalement tous les
spectateur se reporte sur les transports
collectifs donc nous avions commencé par
un travail très fin de prévision des
flux de déplacement heure par heure pour
l'ensemble des jours des Jeux Olympiques
des Jeux paralympiques ces ces
estimations de flux sur l'ensemble du
réseau station par station interstation
par interstation tiennent compte à la
fois des spectateur mais aussi de la
demande de fond de la demande du
quotidien des déplacements des des
Franciliens donc sur cette base nous
avons élaboré en partenariat avec les
opérateurs de transport mais aussi donc
avec l'intégralité des acteurs concernés
donc les préfectures de département la
préfecture de police les forces de
l'ordre les services de secours les
collectivités territorial concerné les
gestionnaires de voiri et bien entendu
l'organisateur Paris 2024
nous avons donc pour chaque site
identifié les lignes de transport en
commun qui vont les desservir les gares
ou les stations qui seront concerné par
la desserte des sites tout cela est
cartographié documenté et euh maintenant
Paris 2024 est en train sur cette base
de réaliser les plans les guides qui
seront fournis aux spectateurs
euh et qui seront d'abord mis en ligne
au printemps et puis ensuite envoyer au
aux spectateurs peu avant les
compétitions euh nous avons identifié
les renforts d'offre sur le réseau
ferroviaire puisque l'objectif euh c'est
que ces spectateurs soient transportés
évidemment par le métro par le train par
le RER et parfois par la lignes de
trainoua en revanche on ne mobilise pas
le réseau de bus local pour les
spectateurs juste sur le dernier
kilomètre ce sera le cas en revanche je
y revenir pour les personnes euh à
mobilité réduite euh surtout nous av
avons aussi travailler sur la desserte
de sites qui sont des sites j'ai envie
de dire éphémères puisque plusieurs
sites de de de compétition de de Paris
2024 euh n'en seront pas en fait
forcément après les jeux ou certains euh
seront sont utilisés mais habituellement
avec des jauges qui n'ont absolument
rien à voir à ce qui est prévu pendant
les Jeux Olympiques c'est le cas de de
nombreux sites de grandes couronnes euh
en particulier le stade nautique de de
verre sur marne euh le golf national sur
le plateau de saclet la colline des
lancours un site tout nouveau et
l'étoile royale à Versailles he donc à
l'ouest du parc du château quia les
épreuves
d'équitation pour ces sites nous allons
mettre en place des navettes bus à haute
capacité parce que ces sites ont tous la
particularité d'être éloignés des gares
on ne peut pas y accéder à pied depuis
les gares il faut donc mettre en place
des navettes à haute capacité navettes
qui seront exploitées par Transdev ou la
croix sa VAC euh nous complétons Florent
Bardon vient de de de l'indiquer euh
nous nous travaillons encore sur
quelques plans qui sont plus
problématiques euh c'est le cas de de la
desserte de Roland Garos et du Parc des
Princes euh pour lesquels là c'est des
sites je veux dire on a vous allez me
dire on a l'habitude de les desservir
oui mais euh il n'y a pas d'habitude 100
% des spectateurs qui viennent au
transport en commun euh on est même
plutôt sur du euh 50 % qui qui viennent
en transport collectif donc il faut
passer à une échelle supérieure euh pour
passer à cette échelle supérieure la la
desserte par le métro ne suffit pas euh
il va donc falloir inciter les
spectateurs à utiliser aussi le rerc et
nous mettons en place euh pour accroître
les capacités de dessert des navettes
bus euh qui notamment permettront la
desserte de Roland Garos depuis la Porte
Dauphine et du Parc des Princes depuis
l'avenue Foche
les études continuent sur les sites de
célébration et les cérémonies
d'ouverture alors sur les sites de
célébration parce que nous n'en
connaissons pas
encore complètement la teneur notamment
parce que certains sites de célébration
sont vont être mis en œuvre par les
collectivités locales qui sont en train
de mener des appels d'offre pour
identifier des prestataires événementiel
donc du coup nous attendons d'avoir la
programmation pour pouvoir travailler
sur les plans de transport
de de ces sites hein ce qui
effectivement va quand même poser
quelques difficultés en terme de
calendrier et puis nous travaillons sur
les cérémonies d'ouverture qui sont on
le sait on le sait des événements
complexes nous avons aussi identifié les
parcs relais alors voilà pour arriver à
ce 100 % transport en commun nous savons
que certains spectateurs souhaiteront
venir en voiture donc ils ne pourront
pas venir en voiture jusqu'au site en
revanche nous allons mettre en avant des
parcs relais si situé le long des
réseaux ferroviaires qui permettront via
un trajet raisonnable complémentaire en
transport en commun de rejoindre ces
site ces parcs relais seront ouverts
avec un système de réservation ce qui
permettra d'en assurer la la
disponibilité en parallèle de l'offre de
transport un travail très important est
en cours sur l'information voyageur donc
nous développons une application
spéciale pour les Jeux Olympiques qui
sera la petite sœur de l'application une
de France mobilité habituelle elle sera
simplifiée en terme d'in interface elle
sera effectivement au look of the Games
et surtout elle elle mettra en avant dès
l'écran d'accueil les sites olympiques
que le spectateur pourra d'ailleurs
mettre en favori avec des règles de
calcul des itinéraires aussi qui seront
adapté aux enjeux de de gestion de flux
au-delà des transports en commun on
trouvera aussi son itinéraire à vélo sur
notre application et puis à pied quand
on est dans des distances raisonnables
pour utiliser la marche pour se rendre
au site de compétition euh au-delà de de
l'application de de cette information
numérique euh déjà évoqué par par
Florent mais je pourrais aussi y revenir
concernant le la relation avec les
autres calculateurs d'itinéraire nous
menons un travail important avec les
opérateurs de transport sur la signal
éthique euh là aussi il s'agit
d'orienter les flux de spectateurs vers
les itinéraires conseillés pour se
rendre sur les sites des Jeux Olympiques
notre application aura aussi une
fonctionnalité billetique ce qui veut
dire que le spectateur pourra acheter
ces titres de transport les avoir sur
son smartphone et valider avec son
smartphone il pourra aussi pour ceux qui
possèdent des des cartes Navigo
recharger sa carte Navigo avec les
titres de transport de son choix
directement avec son smartphone en terme
donc l'information voyageur va jouer
évidemment un rôle très important en
terme de gestion de flux mais cette
gestion de flu elle va reposer également
sur des moyens humains très conséquents
qui seront déployés dans les gares et
station et dans les zones de déposuse
reprise des navettes bus je pense que
les opérateurs RATP SNCF vont vont
détailler donc je je ne vais pas le le
faire dans dans un premier temps par
ailleurs donc nous commençons
l'élaboration des plans de contingence
parce qu'effectivement nous anticipons
que tout ne va pas évidemment se passer
parfaitement comme on peut l'imaginer de
de manière théorique ces plans de
contingence ils vont permettre de faire
face à toutes les difficultés qui
pourraient survenir en premier lieu
concernant les événements organisés par
Paris
2024 nombre de compétitions se passent
en en extérieur sont soumises aux aléas
météorologiques il peut y avoir des
reports d'épreuves des décalages de
demi-journée voir l'utilisation de
journée de réserve donc nous nous
organisons pour faire face à tout à
toutes ces ces toutes ces ces ces
phénomènes disruptif qui pourrait qui
pourrait survenir et nous anticipons
aussi les défaillances du réseau de
transport en commun en commençant par
anticiper les reports qui se qui se
produiraient au cas où une ligne
finalement ne fonctionnerait pas euh ça
va être l'élaboration de ces plans B va
être facilité par le fait que nous avons
cherché même pour les sites de grande
couronne donc éloigné des sites éloigné
des gares du du réseau ferroviaire nous
avons cherché à assurer une redondance
dans l'offre qui qui qui va être
proposée et donc à pouvoir disposer
effectivement de de solutions de repli
l'élaboration de ces plans s nourrit
aussi aussi des Test Event qui ont lieu
cet été en particulier à la colline des
lancours et vont évidemment s'affiner au
fur et à mesure des exercices une
attention particulière est porté aux
spectateurs en situation de handicap
donc au-delà de l'accessibilité du
réseau nous mettons en place un système
de navette sur réservation pour les
spectateurs en fauteuil roulant ce
système fonctionnera entre les grandes
gares parisiennes et l'ensemble des
sites de compétition pourquoi ce ce
système spécifique parce que nous
anticipons une affluence très importante
dans les transports en commun parce que
les capacités des ascenseurs dans les
gares accessibles ne sont pas
suffisantes pour faire face aux jauges
qui sont prévu par Paris 2024 pour les
personnes en fauteuil roulant et puis
parce que ce sera quand même beaucoup
plus confortable en terme de de de
transport hein par exemple pour se
rendre à à ver surmarne donc au-delà du
réseau de de transport féré il faut
prendre après ad naavette il faut
prendre il faut encore marcher pendant
un certain temps ce sera quand même
beaucoup plus pratique euh voilà et puis
donc pour finir nous contribuons à la
démarche de travel dem management en
fournissant l'ensemble des informations
heure par heure là aussi tronçon par
tronçon gare par gare pour que les
Franciliens puissent apprécier où et
quand se produira de la congestion ou de
la forte affluence dans les réseau de de
transport en commun et prendre les
dispositions adaptées remerci merci
maintenant la parole est à Monsieur
Edgar
C ah non alors Monsieur Frédéric dupoui
qui qui commence donc B
merci bonjour madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les parlementaires donc je me
présente je suis Frédéric dupouille
directeur de influence territoirale
internationale au sein de la RATP au
secrétariat général à mes côté Edgar C
qui est responsable de la mission jop
cette mission a pour objet de de
préparer et d'organiser l'entreprise qui
est la RATP avec l'ensemble des
directions et des filèles du groupe en
lien avec tous les acteurs externes de
l'entreprise elle est rattaché
directement au président euh de la RATP
Jean Castex euh tout d'abord je tenais à
vous remercier pour nous donner la
parole dans cette table ronde le Groupe
RATP s'apprête à vivre une année 2024
très importante qui placera le transport
au cœur de la réussite des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques 2024 d'ors
et déjà nous pouvons nous réjouir comme
vousz comme Florent a pu le faire de la
Coupe du monde de rugby qui s'est
effectivement bien déroulé du point de
vue des transports collectifs sur tous
les sites et notamment en Île-de-France
euh mais les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques ce sera une toute autre
échelle comme a pu le souligner
également Florent à
l'instant pour cela l'entreprise toute
entière et collectivement est au côté du
du Comité d'Organisation Paris 2024 pour
garantir une meilleure expérience
voyageurs au millions de voyageurs qui
emprunteront chaque jour le réseau pour
se rendre sur les sites de compétition
et la RATP représentera 70 % des voyages
qui se feront par une ligne opéré par la
RATP euh l'entreprise en tant que
premier opérateur en Île-de-France et et
l'ensemble de ses collaborateurs se
prépare déjà depuis plusieurs mois
plusieurs années également pour garantir
la meilleure expérience et nous serons
au rendez-vous de cette exp de cette
événement sportif majeur et
international en lien avec toutes les
parties prenantes notre auteur é
organisatrice bien évidemment
île-defance mobilité la préfecture de
police le cojot l'État dans toutes ces
composantes la M de Paris également nos
collègues de la SNCF ici présents nos
défis sont multiples assurer l'accueil
et le service de visiteurs pour le monde
du monde entier des personnes en
situation de handicap on l'a vu à
l'instant on pourra y revenir assurer la
robustesse du plan transport pour
desservir dans les meilleures conditions
tous les sites de la
compétition au total ce seront 19000
agents de la RATP conducteurs
machinistes c'estd conducteur de bus
agents des gares et des stations agents
de sûreté également qui seront mobilisés
chaque jour sur le réseau ainsi que des
équipes de volontaires qui seront
mobilisés on l'a dit pour être au
service des voyageurs visiteurs d'ors et
déjà plus de 3000 volontaires agents au
sein de l'entreprise et proches
pressentis ont déjà répondu à notre
appel en interne enfin les Jeux
Olympiques c'est également sont
également synonyme d'héritage pour les
Franciliens qui vont bénéficier du
prolongement l' dit également à
l'instant de la ligne 14 de pleel à
l'aéroport d'Orly la ligne sera le
premier éritage de cet événement au
rayonnement mondial et bénéficiera aux
usagers du quotidien permettant
d'alléger notamment le RERB dans sa
partie
sud pour finir je tenais
à clore mon propos liminaire et je
voulais remercier le
législateur de la prise en compte de la
PPL concurrence bus qui qui fournit qui
est en cours évidemment de d'examen et
qui fournit qui va fournir des réponses
aux salariés concernés et qui sera un
facteur d'apaisement social
euh pour ces Jeux Olympiques 2024 voilà
je vous remercie de m'avoir écouté merci
donc maintenant la parole est à Monsieur
Durieux bonjour et merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président Madame
et Messieurs les Députés les je
olympique et paralympique 2024 s'annonce
comme étant vous l'avez compris le plus
extraordinaire événement sportif jamais
organisé en France inutile de rappeler
tout ce qu' a déjà été cité et souligné
à plusieurs reprises dans les
interventions précédentes et qui sont
connu de tous maintenant en terme de
nombre de spectateurs d'athlètes
d'accrédités de couverture médiatique
d'événements festifs la mobalité bien
entendu un enjeu majeur de la réussite
des jeux de paris 2024 et le groupe SNCF
impliqué dès la phase de candidature
sera un acteur central de la mobilité
baccarbone de cette olympiadeve avec
notamment l'engagement prix par Paris
2024 d'avoir 100 % des sites olympiques
accessibles en transport en commun pour
les
spectateurs soulignons également dans le
même temps que pour SNCF les périodes
des jeux coïcid pour les Jeux olympiques
du 26 juillet au 11 août avec trois
weekends de grand départ au plein cœur
de l'été la cérémonie d'ouverture le
vendredi d'un de la veille d'un grand
départ
euh ben pendant lesqueles évidemment les
grandes gares sont très sollicité et
pour les Jeux paralympiques du 28 août
au 8 septembre nous coincidons avec le
dernier weekend de grand retour et la
première semaine de la rentrée scolaire
donc desservir 39 sites sur toute la
France avec plus de 80 % des épreuves en
Île-de-France tout en assurant le
transport de nos clients habituels et
donc un bel objectif un défi pour nous
et pour cela le groupe B agira en
premier lieu avec notre activité snsf
Transilien pour le compte de l'opérateur
île- de France mobilité avec tous les
travaux et les chantiers que a énuméré
Laurence de brinca ici présente mais
cela concernera aussi nos autres
activités voyageur TGV Intercité et TER
pour les épreuves organisées en région à
Lille à Marseille Nice Nantes Bordeaux
Lyon Saint-Étienne et
châteurou je soulignerai aussi notre
implication dans le programme de la
billetterie nationale populaire pour le
transport des scolaires depuis tous les
territoires vers Paris pour assister au
aux Jeux paralympiques dans le cadre du
programme de ce programme d'État enfin
bien évidemment le groupe SNCF sera
concerné par sa filiale sa société Kolis
notamment à lî Bordeaux Lyon et
châteurou puisque les transports publics
sont réalisés par cette société dans ces
villes Koli sera aussi impliqué pour les
comment les transports en Île-de-France
en particulier des navettes UFR dont a
parlé île-de-fance mobilité à l'instant
mais également une partie contribuera ce
qui est le cas aussi pour les
territoires au transport des athlètes
pour le compre de î de France mobilité
et de Paris 2024 enfin le groupe SNCF
sera concerné par nos gestionnaires
d'infrastructure et de gare SNCF réseau
et gare et connexion ou encore notre
direction de la sûreté ferroviaire et
notre direction du médrique pour les
questions et les enjeux de sécurité et
de cybersécurité qui comme vous savez
sont prignants dans ce type
d'organisation alors quand on se dit
tout ça on mesure l'empleur de ce qui
est devant nous et ben moi je voudrais
dire que nous sommes confiants en fait
dans la livraison en fait de cet év pour
trois raisons principales la première
raison c'est que le groupe SNCF dispose
d'un savoir-faire d'expérience pour les
transports à l'occasion des grands
événements sportive nous avons toujours
répondu présent à ces grands rendez-vous
c'était déjà le cas au jeudhiv
d'Alberville en 92 à la Coupe du monde
du rugby en 2007 à l'uro en 2016 la
rider Cup en 2018 la Coupe du Monde
féminine en 2019 et bien plus récemment
comme vous le savez la Coupe du monde du
rugby 2023 qui est un succès en terme de
transport je soulignerai ici par rapport
à ce qui a été dit par mon collègue de
la RTP ément notre implication dans le
transport des équipes comme vous avez
certainement pu en dans un mode de
transport bac carbone nous allons
renouveler l'expérience avec le
transport des équipes de football vers
les régions pour le compte de Paris 2024
à l'occasion des
Jeux le deuxième point pour lequel nous
somes confiant c'est que Ben le groupe
se
prépare voilà depuis maintenant 2019
pour préparer les Jeux de Paris 2024 et
s'assurer que tout soit prêt notre
président Jean-Pierre fermandou a fait
le choix de mettre en place une
direction de programme voilà son arrivé
chargé d'anticiper les travaux et animer
l'ensemble des activités sociées de
groupes que je viens d'énumérer à date
nous avons une trentaines de personnes
mobilisées à la fois dans notre
direction de programme à laquelle
j'appartiens mais également en fait dans
avec les chefs de projets dans chacune
de ces sociétés qui sont chargés
d'impulser la démarche et le programme
dans leur entité respective euh donc
après avoir instruit des 2019 les
différents chantiers dont certains ont
été beaucoup sistés donc je vais les
émunérer très rapidement hein la
sécurisation deschantiers à livrés
évoqué par Florent Bardon la définition
de maratoire travaux pour permettre en
fait d'avoir le maximum de capacité
ferroviaire pendant les jeu les plans de
fiabilisation des infrastructures et des
équipements enc pour le groupe pour
lequel le groupe s'est investi compris
en voilà en en numéraire l'élaboration
des plans de transport la définition des
services nous sommes maintenant dans une
rentrés dans une étape préopérationnelle
avec un calage fin de nos dispositifs et
une montée en puissance de nos équipes
de terrain citons la définition des
mesures opérationnelles la définition
des dispositifs de supervision et de
gestion de crise le lancement de notre
programme de volontariat puisque on a
bien vu au travers de la Coupe du Monde
du Rebier que la présence humaine est un
facteur de réussite et donc nous misons
beaucoup évidemment sur une présence
très forte pour orienter ces spectateurs
l'information voyageur avec des outils
multilinguisme pour accueillir ce public
spécifique en particulier les publics
étrangers qui peuvent venir de plus de
200 pays différents euh et puis enfin
nous sécurisons les ressources les
ressources matérielles les ressources
humaines avec un dialogue engager avec
les organisations
syndicales trème point et dernier point
et ça sera ma conclusion nous sommes
confiants parce que comme vous le voyez
ici nous sommes coordonnés nous sommes
coordonnés entre au sein du groupe SN
mais nous sommes coordonnés entre Île de
France mobilité l'État sous voilà on va
dire sous la la bienveillance en fait du
directeur délégué enfin du délégué
pardon interministériau jeux olympiqu
Michel Cado et évidemment sous la
coordination du COORDIN ateur national
de la mobilité des jeux ici présent
Florent pardon nous nous causons et nos
équipes se parlent tous les jours et ça
il me semble que c'est un facteur qui
mérite d'être souligné comme un facteur
de réussite dans la préparation de ces
jeux merci à votre écoute et prédisposé
à répondre à vos
questions merci beaucoup madame Sandrine
Gourlet bonjour madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les députés comme l'a indiqué
Florent Bardon la société du Grand-
Paris est en charge de la réalisation du
prolongement de la ligne 14 donc
conjointement avec la RATP et aéroport
de Paris pour ce qui concerne la Gard
d'orli la Société du Grand Paris est
plus directement en charge de la
réalisation de la gare de saint-liel
alors les travaux avancent bien
conformément au calendrier bien sûr nous
restons vigilants parce qu'on n'est
jamais à l'abri d'Ala mais les délais
sont tenus et nous restons également
vigilants sur les conditions de sécurité
des chantiers qui restent notre priorité
absolue comme je vous le disais les
travaux de la gare de Saint- pleel se
poursuivent à très bon rythme les
travaux d'aménagement battent leur plein
avec près de 400 personnes mobilisées
chaque jour sur le chantier depuis
l'installation des façades de quai de la
ligne 14 jusqu'à l'aménagement du
par-vis de la gare en passant par
l'installation des 56 escaliers
mécaniques que vous pourrez voir à
l'ouverture de la gare parce que ça sera
la gare du Grand Paris Express qui en
conta le plus nous mettons tout en œuvre
pour livrer la gare en juin 2024 et
chaque jour on peut voir si vous vous
rendez sur le site que la gare prend un
peu plus sa forme définitive et donc
nous sommes parfaitement en ligne avec
les différents points de passage que
nous sommes fixés jusqu'à la livraison
la ligne 14 sera exploitée par la RATP
le futur exploitant de la gare de
saint-n pleel est désigné et le travail
entre toutes les équipes avance très
correctement ce qui est un facteur
essentiel de réussite il y a eu de
premiers essais qui ont été fait pendant
les vacances de la toussin qui avait
conduit à une interruption de trafic sur
la ligne 14 pour les usagers réguliers
mais qui nous permet de de voir que le
système
d'automatisme a une réactivité
satisfaisante et que les essais sont
concluants
euh et je rappelle que la ligne 14 sera
100 % accessible comme l'ensemble du
réseau du Grand Paris Express que la
Société du Grand Paris constru
actuellement et en fait pour nous la
ligne 14 va pouvoir lancer le CYC des
futures mises en service du réseau du
Grand Paris Express je vous
remercie merci beaucoup donc nous allons
passer maintenant aux orateurs de groupe
donc mes chers collègues et pour 2
minutes donc je voyais que le président
de la Commission du développement
durable qui me disait que c'était la
même chose dans votre commission
monsieur le Président c'est ça donc 2
minutes pour chacun et donc nous allons
commencer avec le groupe Renaissance
avec belkir
beladad merci madame la Présidente merci
mesdames et messieurs pour vos propos
liminire chers collègues je veux d'abord
vous remercier les uns et les autres
pour votre engagement à contribué à
faire en sorte que les Jeux Olympiques
et parallympique soit une réussite et
une fierté pour notre pays il donnera
non' pas dter avoir au monde entier le
meilleur de nous-mêmes la réussite de la
France à organiser les Jeux sera
notamment jugé à l'Ô de sa capacité à
gérer les déplacements des flux de
personnes qu'il s'agissent des équipes
journalistes personnel mais également de
l'ensemble des spectateurs ainsi que des
usagers habituels pendant la période
estivale le défi est est de taille et
comme vous le savez car ce sont pas
moins de 600000 spectateurs et 200000
personnes accréditées qui devront être
transporté chaque jour et pour être à la
hauteur de l'enjeu la Cour des comptes
estimait qu'il faudrait que les
opérateurs de transport relèvent un défi
capacitaur en assurant la disponibilité
des matériels et des personnels et celui
de la gestion des flux et et de la
capacité d'adaptation en temps réel deux
recommandations avaient été faites
notamment la finalisation des euh des
plans de transport site par site alors
je vous ai entendu tout à l'heure moi je
voudrais avoir des précisions euh tous
ne sont pas finalisés j'aimerais
connaître les difficultés qui se
rencontrer la proportion des sites déjà
déjà eng
euh parce que ça c'est l'un des sujets
importants qui est celui de la gestion
des flux on l'a vu à l'occasion de la
Coupe du monde du rugby lors de la
rencontre entre l'Angleterre et
l'Argentine à Marseille cela soulève
également la question de la coordination
entre les gestionnaires de transport les
organisateurs et la préfecture de police
quels sont les points d'amélioration qui
ont été identifiés je vous
remercie merci chers collègues pour le
groupe rassemblement national la parole
est à anque Cousan merci monsieur
monsieur le Président euh mesdames et
messieurs nous sommes confrontés à un
défi sans précédent pendant les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de Paris
2024 en plus de servir les usagers
habituels les systèmes de transport
devont acheminer jusqu'à 600000
spectateurs par jour vers des sites de
compétition tandis que près de 200000
personnes accréditées emprunteront des
voies réservées l'organisation des
déplacements pendant les Jeux Olympique
se doit de perturber le moins possible
la vie quotidienne des habitants
d'Île-de-France la sur les transports en
commun est considérable d'autant plus
que la plupart des sites de compétition
se trouvent dans un rayon de 10 km
autour du village olympique à Paris et
dans ses environs
immédiats permettant un accès en moins
de 30 minutes à 8 mois de l'ouverture
des jeux Une la situation est à
laarmante et les engagements pris ne
sont pas respectés les lignes 15 16 et
17 ne seront pas opérationnels à temps
et l'accès gratuit à l'ensemble du
réseau pour les Dét enteur de billet est
compromis seul 14 % des stations seront
accessibles en fauteuil roulant contre
10 % actuellement et il y aura un
renfort de seulement 15 % de l'offre de
transport en commun par rapport à un été
classique aucun des grands programmes de
mass transit mode lourd de transport
annoncé dans le dossier de candidature
de Paris 2024 ne sera prêt sans compter
les mesures de de sécurité renforcée
dans le cadre du Plan vigip pirate qui
vont accroître les difficultés de
circulation le monde nous observe
pourriez-vous nous exposer dans une
totale transparence l'état d'avancement
des travaux et vos perspectives quant à
la faisabilité de ces derniers pour
l'ouverture des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques je vous
remercie merci madame la députée pour la
France insoumise Paul
Vanier merci madame la Présidente nous
sommes à à 254 jours du début des Jeux
Olympiques et nous atteignons un seuil
d'alerte 44 % des Franciliens jugent que
leur accueil est une mauvaise chose ils
étaient 22 % à exprimer cette opinion il
y a 2 ans en particulier 81 % d'entre
eux se distinquiit de l'impact des jeux
sur les transports et leur déplacement
pour cause les Franciliens vivent déjà
au quotidien la galère des transports en
commun depuis octobre 2021 leur
situation s'est encore dégradée après
que Valérie pcrè ait décidé de réduire
l'offre de bus de RER de métro de
tramoou pour faire quelques économies
résultat les rames sont bondés les
dessertes non assurées les temps
d'attente s'allongent et les prix du
Navigo s'envolent à ce rythme il
atteindra bientôt les 100 € par mois
c'est dans ce contexte que le
gouvernement et Valéri pcrè se préparent
à plonger le réseau des transports
franciliens dans le chaos en privatisant
la RATP en grande couronne dont je suis
l'élu l'ouverture à la concurrence
pourriit déjà le quotidien des Fran en
et a entraîné la destruction des droits
sociaux des salariés du transport elle
nourrit une crise de recrutement
désormais chronique il manque
aujourd'hui 1061 machinistes à la RATP
pendant les Jeux la région accueillera
16 millions de touristes et le réseau de
transport en commun devra absorber
500000 nouveaux usagers quotidiens
Valérie prcrè la présidente d'idfm
promet une offre augmentée de 15 % par
rapport à l'offre d'été habituelle
comment vous préparez-vous à tenir cette
promesse pouvez-vous nous garantir que
les matériels et les agents affectés aux
lignes du quotidien ne seront pas
mobiliser au dépend des usagers pour
assurer prioritairement la desserte des
sites olympiques enfin quelle garantie
pouvez-vous nous apporter quant au
respect des droits des salariés des
transports je pense notamment au temps
de travail au droit à congé pendant la
période des jeux olympique et
paralympique je vous
remercie merci chers collègues pour le
groupe les répu rublicain la parole est
à Maxime
minot merci monsieur le Président nous
avons été nombreux à le dire moins de
250 jours nous nous sép de la cérémonie
d'ouverture des des Jeux olympiques de
Paris 2024 vous le savez la présidente
l'a dit dans son propos liuminaire nous
animons un groupe de travail chargé du
suivi de la préparation des Jeux
Olympiques et Paris et paralympique
pardon de de Paris 2024 dans notre
commission et je peux vous assurer de la
mobilisation et de la vigilance des
parlementaires sur la question de la
préparation des Jeux la question des des
transports et évidemment crucial
plusieurs milliers de personnes venues
du monde entier seront présentes à Paris
sur la période des jop sans compter bien
évidemment que la planète aura les yeux
rivés sur la France la pleine réussite
de ces jeux est donc un enjeu essentiel
pour notre pays comme l'a dit la
présidente roche dans un rapport de la
Cour des comptes de de juillet 2023 et
notre groupe d'études d'ailleurs a
auditionné les auteurs de ce rapport ces
derniers soulignent l'importance de
finaliser l'ensemble des prendes de
transport site par site pour les Jeux
Olympiques d'ici l'été 2023 et d'engager
le leur déclinisation opérationnelle le
même travail devait également être mené
selon eux pour les Jeux paralympiques
qui soulèvent des difficultés
organisationnel spécifique du fait de
leur déroulement en période de rentrée
scolaire de la même façon la cour
s'inquiétait de l'absence de plan en cas
d'incident et on a été nombreux à en
parler notamment madame de brinca de ce
qui est quand même fréquent sur le
réseau parisien le ministre des
Transports a indiqué lui-même hier à la
représentation nationale lors des
questions au gouvernement que le plan de
circulation serait je cite hardcore et
qu'il représenterait ce plan d'ici la
fin novembre face à ces difficultés de
circulation
annoncées et selon toute logique les
Parisiens devraient donc se rabattre sur
le réseau de transport en commun pour se
déplacer lors de la période des j ma
question est donc simple où en est-on de
de l'élaboration de ces plans de
transport et en particulier
l'élaboration du plan en cas d'incident
et les plans de transport prennent-il en
compte les difficultés de circulation
annoncées hier par le ministre et
pouvez-vous nous faire un point
particulier sur ces ses plans notamment
sur l'aspect accessibilité pour toutes
celles et ceux qui sont en situation
d'handicap merci beaucoup merci monsieur
le député pour le groupe démocrate
Florence lasser merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président le
groupe démocrate est attaché à la
thématique de ce matin et nous sommes
très attentifs aux mesures envisagées
pour optimiser les déplacements à
l'occasion des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris à l'été
2024 je prends la parole ce matin pour
partager avec vous quelques-unes de mes
préoccupations sur ce sujet crucial
avant de venir au fond sur du sujet qui
m'interroge permettez-moi de regretter
l'absence de représentant du secteur
aérien secteur qui sera pourtant clé
pour accueillir nos athlètes et
visiteurs qui viendront participer et
assister au jeux des quatre coins du
monde leur point de vue aurait sans
doute éclairé nos débat sur
l'organisation des déplacements en
Île-de-France à l'été sur le fond je
m'interroge sur les moyens envisagés
pour garantir une mobilité fluide à tous
pendant les jeux alors que le Charles de
Gold Express devait régler une grande
partie des questions liées à l'arrivée
des athlètes et des touristes
internationaux dans Paris la date de sa
mise en service a été repoussée malgré
la création de voies olympiques dédié
qui engloberont le périphérique parisien
et là le risque d'embouteillage
historique plane puisque tout le trafic
entre roissier et la capitale se
concentrera sur la 3 et sur le RERB nul
n'a besoin de connaître l'avenir pour
imaginer que les salariés de l'aéroport
rencontreront de grandes difficultés
pour venir sur leur lieu de travail et
que les touristes seront probablement
déçus de leur premier pas sur notre
territoire face à ces constats le roi
cibus opéré par la RATP a aura un rôle à
jouer pardon mais pourra-t-il palier à
l'ensemble des besoins en matière de
transport entre l'aéroport de Charles-de
Gaulle et Paris
intramuros aussi je souhaiterais
soumettre une idée à île- de France
mobilité pourquoi ne pas proposer des
car des trajets en qu entre Paris et
charles- de Gaul à destination des
salariés de l'aéroport et des passagers
on pourra aller jusqu'à imaginer que ces
cars auraient accès aux voies olympiques
afin de fluidifier les transports
franciliens pendant les Jeux et
permettez-moi d'anticiper une réponse
positive de votre part pourquoi ne pas
envisager de péréniser l'écart dans
l'aprégio jusqu'à la mise en service du
Charles deg Express cela serait selon
moi un héritage positif et durable des
jeux à la mobilité franilienne je vous
remercie merci chers collègues et merci
pour vos propositions constructives pour
le groupe socialiste et apparenté la
parole est à Fatia
kalachi mer merci monsieur le Président
au nom du groupe socialiste et apparenté
je souhaite tout d'abord remercier
chaleureusement chaque intervenant qui a
pris la parole ce matin pour nous
députés d'Île-de-France les alertes
désadministrées sur les problématiques
liées au réseau de transport en commun
régional sont quasi
quotidienne depuis la pandémie du
covid-19 le retour à la normale du
trafic des transports en commun se fait
toujours attendre les victimes de ces
vagons bondés ce sont 12 millions de
voyage quotidien Jean Castex président
de la RATP annoncé le retour à la
normale d'ici le mois de mai dernier
pourtant les alertes autour du réseau
n'ont pas faibli les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques arrivent à grand pas et
nous le savons tous et nous en avons
hâte nous espérons que ce beau moment
sportif se déroulera sans encombre la
demande en transport en commun pour se
rendre aux différents lieux de fête sera
d'une ampleur inédite pouvez-vous nous
préciser quelle augmentation du nombre
d'usagers estimez-vous durant la
compétition enfin pendant ces jeux de
nombreux franciliens continueront à
prendre les transports en commun
quotidiennement pour travailler
parallèlement à ceux qui les utiliseront
pour se rendre aux différents de lieux
de compétition j'aimerais prendre
l'exemple de la ligne 13 la ligne la
plus fréquenté du une des lignes les
plus fréquentées au monde 600000
voyageurs 600000 usagers quotidiens aux
heures de pointe cette ligne 13 est la
ligne de métro la plus proche du Stade
de France donc ma question pouvez-vous
nous préciser si les lignes
franciliennes seront suffisamment
renforcées afin de ne pas mettre en
difficulté les franiliens qui
continueront à les utiliser dans leur
vie quotidienne je vous
remercie merci madame la députée pour
horizon et apparenté Anne Cécile
violent merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président Mesdames Messieurs
chers
collègues tout d'abord merci pour votre
présence ce matin mesdames et messieurs
et vos propos liminires dans quelques
mois effectivement nous aurons le
privilège d'accueillir les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques en France le
monde entier aura les yeux rivé sur la
scène tout d'abord sur Paris mais sur
l'ensemble de notre
territoire près de 200000 personnes
accréditées plus de 50000 volontaires
600000 spectateurs venus du monde entier
seront attendus si de nombreux défis
s'offrent à nous celui des transports
est un élément clé de la réussite de ces
jeux durant 29 jours 41 sites de
compétition olympique dont plus de la
moitié dans les sites franiliens et 20
sites de compétitions paralympique
verront les délégations se succéder les
athlètes performés et le public vibré
une fois de plus cette fête populaire ne
sera possible qu'avec une organisation
optimale du réseau des transports avec
mes collègues du groupe horizon et
horizon et apparenté nous saluons la
mobilisation massive des services de
l'État des collectivités et des
opérateurs nous saluons aussi les choix
réalisés afin de réduire les émissions
carbon en privilégiant les les mobilités
douces et notamment vous l'avez dit en
garantissant la desserte de 100 % des
sites en transport en
commun suite au 8e comité stratégique
des mobilités qui s'est tenu hier vous
avez déjà fait état de quelques avancées
de la programmation des transports mais
pourriez-vous nous préciser davantage
des points très concrets exemple vous
parlez de 415 km de piste cyclab où en
esttant dans la réalisation effective de
ces pistes et en toute transparence
quelles sont vos inquiétudes quelles
sont vos inquiétudes sur les retards
voire les impossibilités à tenir le
calendrier enfin c a déjà été évoqué
pouvez-vous aussi nous préciser si le
déplacement des Français qui
continueront à travailler pendant cette
période a été pensé de manière
spécifique
merci merci chers collègu pour le groupe
écologiste la parole est
lis merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
Messieurs chers collègues avec les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques le fleu de
passagers va a priori doubler sur la
période tout porte malheureusement à
croire qu'il y aura de sévères
difficultés pendant ces jeux je pense
d'abord aux personnes en situation de
handicap alors ça a été évoqué dans vos
propos liminires pratiquement aucune
station de métro parisienne est adaptée
les dessertes en transport en commun
vers les sites des hautes scèes et du
Val de Marne nécessitent parfois fois 10
à 20 minutes de marche pas évident pour
les personnes à mobilité réduite
idem pour nos aînés leur demandera-t-on
de marcher plusieurs kilomètres en plein
été au milieu de la foule ces personnes
devront-elles obligatoirement se
déplacer en taxi ou avec quelques bus y
aura-t-il assez de taxis adaptés
pourriez-vous nous donner quelques
chiffres à ce sujet je pense enfin aux
nombreuses personnes qui travailleront
pendant les Jeux le choix des
implantations s'est fait sans réfléchir
aux répercussions que cela aurait sur le
transport des passagers les lignes déjà
surchargées vont devenir impraticables
je ne vais prendre l'exemple que
l'exemple du RERB qui connaît des
défaillances dues au manque
d'investissement dans le réseau le Stade
de France qu'il desserre va se remplir
et se vider tous les jours vider le
Stade de France c'est remplir le RERB
pendant 2 heures entières bref c'est
rendre la vie Imposs possible au
francilien à cela s'ajoute que 170 km de
voies d'autoroute et de périphérique
seront fermés des bus réquitionnés pour
la presse et les athlètes comment vont
se déplacer les Français qui
travailleront y compris ceux qui celles
et ceux qui travailleront à
l'organisation des Jeux il y avait des
solutions à mettre en œuvre la ville de
Paris s'était engagée à ce que tous les
sites soient accessibles à vélo
l'engagement sera-t-il tenu alors vous
avez évoqué des stationnements
temporaires et l'augmentation des
capacités des services de vélo en libre
service mais on peine à y croire à
quelques mois du début des Jeux il y
avait aussi des propositions à ne pas
mettre en œuvre les taxis volants un
service de luxe énergivore qui ne répond
à aucun besoin de mobilité source de
pollution sonore insupportable pour les
habitantes et les habitants en
particulier du 15e arrondissement et du
nord de l'Essonne est-il prévu de
renoncer à cette
aberration merci madame la députée pour
le groupe GDR stéan peu oui merci madame
la Présidente je à mon tour je remercie
tous tous les orateurs notre pays est
mobilisé il faut réussir ces ces jeux et
je vous remercie tous de vos propos
liminires et de vos de vos engagements
la candidature de Paris 2024 euh porter
euh euh entre autres l'accessibilité de
tous les lieux de compétition par les
transports collectifs donc il y a un
immense enjeu de transport et dans un
rapport parlementaire que j'ai commis
avec mon collègue Stéphane Mazar le
point d'alerte principal sur la
l'organisation des des j au moment où on
publiait notre rapport était celui des
transports et ça reste quand même le
point d'alerte principal je m'étonne que
dans la candidature de Paris 2024 il est
figuré noir sur blanc le développement
du transport fluvial qui reste quand
même quelque chose de peu utilisé en
Île-de-France de transport pour
les voyageurs et de ne pas avoir vu
aucun d'entre vous évoquer cet aspect
mais enfin je voudrais aller très
rapidement à quelques questions pourquoi
n'arrivons-nous pas à mettre en œuvre le
couplage d'un billet d'accès au stade
avec l'accès au transport en commun euh
qui permettrait de d'inciter à
l'utilisation de ce transport et puis
enfin euh grosse inquiétude quand même
sur les les les négociations euh euh
sociales
euh le représentant de la RATP disait
que ça allait la PPL sur l'ouverture des
bus à la concurrence é un outil
d'apaisement social je vois pas en quoi
puisque nous avons auditionné tous les
syndicats de la RATP qui sont tous
unanimement opposé à cette ouverture à
la concurrence donc je ne vois pas
comment le maintien irréaliste du
calendrier prévu par Madame pcres puisse
être source d'apaisement social et puis
par ailleurs il va falloir une
mobilisation très forte euh du personnel
dans tous les domaines en ce mois d'août
2024 où en sont les négociations
sociales dans vos différentes entreprise
pour permettre à chacun d'être au
rendez-vous de cette mobilisation de cet
accueil de de de au moment où la France
le monde entier regardera notre pays et
nos capacités à bien organiser un tel
événement merci chers collègues pour le
groupe liberté indépendant outre maire
et territoire la parole est à Béatrice
DESC merci monsieur le président madame
la Présidente je voudrais moi aussi
remercier tout d'abord l'ensemble des
des intervenants l'année 2024 sera une
grande année pour le sport et pour la
France ce grand honneur qui nous est
fait entraîne avec lui de nombreux
sujets de taille dont celui des des
transports le sujet premier que je
tenais à aborder bien sûr la question de
l'accessibilité des des jeux et du tout
Paris aux personnes en situation de
handicap problématique mise en exerg à à
l'occasion des gios et pourtant
paralpique mais qui est malheureusement
l'attente et se pose chaque jour pour de
nombreux utilisateurs des transports en
commun francilien il y aura-t-il un
effort particulier déployant en la
matière vous avez parlé de navettes et
pérénisé pour l'ensemble des Parisiens
et touristes en situation de handicap
d'ailleurs qu'en est-il euh le temps des
zoo pour que ce que j'appellerai la vie
courante c'est-à-dire les milliers de
franiliens qui vont effectuer leur
trajet quotidien pour aller au travail
et pour qui Paris ne saurait être
impraticable comment peut-on envisager
de maintenir une circulation parallèle
suffisante pour ne pas entraver la vie
parisienne où en est-on par exemple du
recrutement de nouveaux conducteurs et
ces nouveaux dispositifs seront-ils
maintenus à l'issue des jeux dans une
logique d'optimisation du réseau de
transport francilien l'une des clés de
réussite de ces jeux c'est qu'il puisse
avoir lieu dans une acceptabilité
générale sans pénaliser la vie
quotidienne des habitants de la région
île-defance je vous
remercie merci madame la députée donc
vous voyez que nous avons de nombreuses
questions Mesdames et Messieurs nos
invités et donc on va vous laisser le
soin d'y répondre peut-être en
commençant par Monsieur Bardon et puis
ensuite vous verrez qui souhaite pour
compléter les les réponses des questions
de nos
collègues merci madame la Présidente
peut-être un un premier point autour des
des plans de transport qui a été évoqué
par plusieurs d'entre vous euh d'abord
pour redire que dans leur immense
majorité les plans de transport sont
stabilisés euh il reste du travail sur
quelques cas qui sont plus difficiles
mais plus spécifiques aussi
h on peut penser à l'événement dans
l'événement qui est la la cérémonie
d'ouverture des Jeux Olympiques et
l'ensemble d'ailleurs des Céré ouverture
et clôture sur lesquel là les travaux
sont clairement encore en cours pour le
reste euh mais je laisserai évidemment
Laurence vous précisez ça mais les plans
de transport sont stabilisés je
mentionnais Paris Ouest tout à l'heure
parce que nous avons un défi particulier
sur certains jours où les sites de
Roland Garros et du Parc des Princes
sont activés en même temps et le Parc
des Princes reçoit plusieurs
compétitions ce jour-là donc c'est sur
ces jours précis et où nous sommes en en
train finalement de j'allais dire
de de finaliser l'ensemble des des
mesures très détaillées avec notamment
l'organisation de finalement de tests de
circulation des navettes avec nos
collègues de la RATP les navettes qui
ont été mentionnées tout à l'heure par
Madame de brinca qui viennent en
complément du du réseau de de transport
pour ces jours-là un test qui sera
organisé le 10 décembre si je ne m'abuse
donc vous voyez qu'on est dans la la
finalisation et la les tests pratiques
pour la mise en œuvre de de ces plans de
transport
alors évidemment on va continuer à à
travailler et à affiner ces plans de
transport presque presque jusqu'au
bout
donc donc voilà le travail continue mais
dans leur grande majorité les les les
plans pour l'ensemble des sites
d'Île-de-France sont sont désormais
arrêtés et nous sommes dans une phase
plutôt de de consolidation de rédaction
des guides spectateurs comme le
mentionnait également î- defance
mobilité tout à l'heure donc évidemment
quand on est en train de de rédiger
les indications pour se rendre sur les
sites c'est bien que les les plans de
transport sont sont définitivement
arrêtés les offres ont
été renforcé et voté pour se faire en
conseil d'administration d'île-defance
mobilité pour donner les moyens aux
opérateurs SNCF et RATP de de déployer
les offres les offres
complémentaires peut-être revenir aussi
en lien avec avec l'offre sur les
questions que vous avez posé concernant
le les déplacements du quotidien pour
pour les
Franciliens évidemment c'est c'est
l'autre objectif majeur de de succès
c'est c'est bien d'accueillir le monde
pour les Jeux Olympiques et d'accueillir
l'ensemble des spectateurs c'est mieux
si la cité peut continuer à vivre le
plus normalement possible il est
indéniable qu'il y aura des impacts sur
les réseaux de transport d'une manière
générale que ça soit sur le réseau de
transport en commun ou sur le réseau
routier l'offre de transport en commun
est augmenté de 15 % en moyenne ça a été
rappelé mais c'est une moyenne et les
moyens sont
réparti de manière à faire face sur les
lignes les plus sollicitées donc au
moment et aux endroits les plus
sollicités les 15 % c'est vraiment une
moyenne par rapport à un été à un été
classique et il est bien évident qu'il y
a une concentration de moyens sur les
lignes les plus
sollicitées au moments les plus les plus
chargés par ailleurs sur le le réseau de
de voie enfin sur la voirie en général
plusieurs plusieurs éléments là encore
euh l'offre au contraire elle va être
contrainte contrainte par deux types de
dispositifs différents le dispositif de
voie olympique réservé à la circulation
des véhicules des accrédités euh mais
sur lesquels pourront circuler également
les transports en commun les taxis
évidemment les les véhicules d'urgence
et donc ce ne sont pas des fermetures de
d'axes de circulation ce sont bien des
fermetures d'une voie sur certaines
autoroutes et sur le sur le périphérique
on n'est pas sur la ferme fermeture
complète euh des des voies express que
ce soit le périphérique ou les
autoroutes mais par contre évidemment ça
réduit la capacité routière disponible
l'autre modalité de restriction de de
l'offre ce sont les périmètres de
sécurité aux abords des sites avec un
système progressif finalement qui sera
qui sera mis en place avec des zones de
déviation du trafic de transit et puis à
mesure qu'on se rapproche vraiment très
exactement des sites olympiques des
mesures de de restriction que chacun
peut comprendre pour éviter que les
véhicules puissent se mélanger avec la
foule au moment où les stades se
remplissent ou se vident euh pour faire
face et pour informer l'ensemble des des
Franciliens de ces de ces impacts je
mentionnais tout à l'heure la démarche
de travel demand management euh l'idée
c'est on joue sur l'offre et notamment
sur l'offre de transport en commun pour
la renforcer mais il faut aussi qu'on
puisse jouer sur la demande de manière
ciblée euh aux endroits et au aux heures
les plus chargées pour expliquer que oui
effectivement certains jours à certaines
heures prendre la ligne 9 pour son
trajet habituel pour se rendre à son
travail par exemple si on peut éviter il
faut le
faire ça peut passer par de l'incitation
à du télétravail ça peut passer par de
l'incitation à changer de mode de
déplacement euh donc c'est ces
différentes informations que nous
allons progressivement donner à
l'ensemble à l'ensemble des des
Franciliens donc les impacts généraux
sur les transports pour indiquer les
horaires auxquels auxquels le réseau
sera sera le plus chargé il est certain
qu'il y aura des périodes d'affluence
qui seront différentes de celles
d'habitude compte tenu de l'accueil de
l'accueil des spectateurs donc nous
comptons jouer sur l'offre d'une part
mais aussi sur le levier de la demande
pour orienter un petit peu différemment
de l'habitude les déplacements du
quotidien évidemment l'enjeu c'est de de
minimiser ces impacts euh de minimiser
la gêne occasionnée pour l'ensemble des
des Franciliens il faut que la la vie de
la cité puisse continuer à s'organiser
on a un travail tout particulier avec
les acteurs de la logistique qui sont
des flux essentiels non seulement pour
l'organisation des Jeux mais également
pour l'approvisionnement euh de de Paris
et de l'ensemble de la région
île-de-fance pour leur permettre de
pouvoir circuler en adaptant leurs
horaires de livraison par exemple et en
adaptant les modalités prévues le rythme
des livraisons et cetera et cetera donc
ce ces impacts sont bien pris en compte
dans la préparation des Jeux à la fois
sur le le volet de l'offre et sur le
volet de la demande
euh je voulais également revenir
sur ce qui a été mentionné concernant le
la Coupe du monde de rugby rapidement
monsieur béadad je crois que c'est vous
qui avez posé la question avec le les
les le premier weekend de la Coupe du
monde à Marseille il y a eu lors du
premier match à Marseille euh des
spectateurs qui sont arrivés en retard
au au stade alors c'était pas tellement
lié à une problématique sur le réseau de
transport en tant que tel mais plutôt
une problématique de gestion de l'espace
public et des accès au stade où
l'ensemble des spectateurs qui étaient
qui étaient dans le métro marseillais
sont sortis par la même sortie et du
coup il y a eu une euh une queue qui
s'est formée pour pouvoir rentrer au
stade donc ce problème a été résolu euh
très rapidement finalement avec la
diffusion de la bonne information auprès
des voyageurs dans le dans le réseau de
métro marseillais pour leur indiquer
qu'il y avait une autre sortie
permettant un autre accès au stade et il
n'y a plus ensuite ce type de de
congestion finalement pour le pour
l'arrivée des spectateurs donc c'est
évidemment un retour d'expérience qu'on
qu'on prend qu'on prend en compte c'est
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure sur
le les grands événement enfin les les
Test Event d'une part et le grand
événement qui a constitué la Coupe du
monde de rugby on a prendre ces
événements pour être pour être prêt
l'année prochaine évidemment aussi sur
les la traduction en anglais notamment
de ces annonces pour pour orienter le le
public ce qui n'était ce qui n'était pas
le cas lors du premier weekend de la
Coupe du monde de rugby à Marseille mais
ça a été ça a été corrigé immédiatement
voilà sur ce ce premier point sur le sur
l'offre et sur le et sur la demande de
transport peut-être un un seconde
thématique qui a été évoqué sur le vélo
donc sur le le réseau de de 415 km de de
piste cyclable euh je reprends mon petit
tableau nous en sommes aujourd'hui à 340
km de piste qui sont belle bien réalisé
existante mise en service euh 43 km qui
sont des projets pérennes qui restent
encore à livrer donc qui sont en cours
de de chantier et les 32 km restants qui
seront des aménagements provisoires euh
donc voilà nous suivons au quotidien le
l'avancée de ces différents chantiers et
nous sommes tout à fait confiants sur la
la réalité de cette promesse sur le vélo
euh associé comme je le disais tout à
l'heure au stationnement provisoire aux
abords des sites et à l'augmentation des
flottes de vélo en libre service avec
pour vlib 20000 20000 Vélib disponibles
à l'horizon des Jeux Olympiques et pour
les les opérateurs de Free floating de
23 à 25000 vélos euh selon les les
avancées des négociations en cours entre
les opérateurs et les
collectivités voilà sur ces points je
regarde les autres questions que vous
aviez posé euh pour continuer à répondre
peut-être sur plus spécifiquement sur
euh
euh sur l'accessibilité des personnes à
mobilité réduite donc l'ensemble des des
dispositions qui sont prises sont de
différents ordres il y a d'abord
l'accessibilité du réseau existant qui
est qui est Escalé effectivement le
métro historique n'est pas accessible
mais certaines lignes le sont par
exemple la ligne 14 donc évidemment les
dispositifs j'allais dire de de droit
courant et
d'accessibilité courante continueront à
être disponibles pendant les Jeux
olympique pour autant pour faire face à
la la jauge exceptionnelle de de
personnes à mobilité réduite qui sera
présente pendant les les périodes
olympique et paralympique il y a un
service additionnel de navette que
Laurence de Branca a évoqué tout à
l'heure qui servira grosso modo les
grandes gardes d'Île de France et chacun
des sites olympiques qui est qui est
mise en place spécifiquement euh donc je
n'y reviens pas et peut-être pour pour
préciser également un autre volet de ce
plan qui concerne les taxis accessibles
euh nous avions fait le constat il y a
un peu plus d'un an de ça que environ
200 taxis étaient accessibles aux
personnes en fauteuil roulant seulement
et donc l'état s'est engagé dans un plan
de développement
pour offrir 1000 taxis accessibles à
l'horizon des jeux ça passe par deux
volets le volet de la délivrance de
nouvelles licences pour les taxis des
autorisations de stationnement euh donc
une partie de ces licences ont été
délivrées pour les personnes physiques
une partie de ces licences est en cours
d'examen et sera délivré d'ici la fin de
l'année par la préfecture de police pour
les les personnes morales qui en ont
fait la demande à l'issue d'un appel à
manifestation d'intérêt d'un appel à
projet cet automne et le deuxième volet
sur ces taxis c'est évidemment la
construction et la la livraison des
véhicules en tant que tels avec un
dispositif d'incitation financière pour
pour s'équiper en véhicule en véhicule
compatible et à ce jour nous avons reçu
850 demandes de de subvention et donc
850 commandes de véhicules ce qui
ajouter aux 200 au 200 taxis qui
existent nous permettra d'atteindre la
cible des 1000 des 1000 taxis pour les
pour les Jeux Olympiques et donc les
premiers véhicules commencent à être
livrés ou commenceront à être livrés
d'ici la fin de l'année
euh voilà pour pour ce point sur
l'accessibilité ce que ce que je
souhaitais ajouter il y a sans doute
encore beaucoup d'autres points sur
lesquels j'ai pas j'ai pas forcément
répondu mais jeis peut-être laissé mes
petits camarades compléter oui tout à
fait sachant qu'on a une quinzaine de
questions et que vous aurez largement
l'occasion de revenir sur un certain
nombre de points donc je ne sais pas qui
souhaite prendre la parole maintenant
pour compléter madame de
brinca oui merci je voulais déjà
compléter par rapport au nombre de
déplacements en transport en commun
qu'on attend pendant les Jeux Olympiques
avant la crise sanitaire on avait à peu
près 9 millions de déplacements chaque
jour sur le réseau de de transport en
commun franilien on n pas retrouvé ce
niveau notamment enfin avec l'impact du
télétravail he on est on est toujours en
dessous de de ce niveau euh on n'attend
pas plus de déplacement en fait pendant
les Jeux euh pourquoi parce que l'été
habituellement on a déjà une baisse
d'environ 1/3 euh des déplacements en
transport en commun puisque les les
enfants euh les les les élèves ne ne
vont plus au collège au lycée euh euh ou
ni ni les étudiants euh et puis parce
que les actifs prennent prennent leur
congé euh donc finalement les
spectateurs Jeux Olympiques vont venir
en fait compenser cette baisse
habituelle de l'été alors en revanche
euh si on n' pas globalement plus de
déplacements ils ne seront pas au même
endroit et pas au même moment
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait une grosse
partie des déplacements en transport en
commun se passe habituellement en grande
couronne par exemple pour justement des
déplacements scolaires là évidemment ils
seront concentrés dans Paris ou à
proximité des sites de compétition c'est
pour cela que les renforts sont ciblés
les renforts d'offres sont ciblés
justement sur ces périodes qui le
nécessitent euh donc effectivement
Florent Bardon l' l'a rappelé hein donc
aujourd'hui les les les les plans de
transport pour se rendre au sites de
compétition sont tous terminés tous
terminés ceux qui ne sont pas terminés
c'est effectivement la cérémonie
d'ouverture des Jeux Olympiques des Jeux
paralympiques qui ne posera pas de
problème particulier d'ailleurs pour les
Jeux paralympiques et puis les dessert
des sites de célébration parce que
autant les compétitions on les connaît
depuis la candidature he voilà on sait
qu'il y a des épreuves de badminton à
tel endroit et cetera autant les
célébrations celles-là on les connaît
depuis peu voire on les connaît pas
encore
donc évidemment c'est compliqué de faire
des plans de transport sur des choses
qu'on ne connaît pas encore quand on n'
pas les horaires quand on n' pas les
jauges de ce qui va se passer par
exemple au parc georgevbon on ne peut
pas travailler sur le plan de transport
du parc George Valbon donc on pourra
d'ici quelques semaines maintenant mais
pour l'instant ça n'est ça n'a pas
encore été été le cas donc pour les
sites de compétition effectivement les
plans sont ficelés nous sommes vraiment
maintenant dans le d'abord la
finalisation des avenant au contrat avec
les opérateurs qui passeront au conseil
d'administration du de France mobilité
euh du mois de de février et qui sera
donc il a déjà une série d'avenant et
donc on y aura une deuxième série au
conseil de de février euh et puis
surtout maintenant dans un un travail de
micro détail avec les acteurs locaux
j'ai envie de dire de la même manière
que les forces de l'ordre sont dans un
travail de micro détail nous sommes dans
ce travail de micro détail où sont les
panneaux de signalétiqu euh est-ce
qu'ils sont bien positionné par entre ce
qui va se passer dans les transports en
commun et ce qui va se passer sur
l'espace public où sont les volontaires
est-ce qu'on a on a bien le bon relais
entre les volontaires des collectivités
les les volontaires ou les agents des
des opérateurs donc vous voyez c'est
vraiment ce travail maintenant
d'ajustement extrêmement fin qui est en
cours euh j'ai entendu la question
concernant la la surcharge des lignes de
transport qui sont utilisés par les
franciliens et qui pour le coup euh
restent fortement utilisé l'été comme le
le le RB ou la ligne 13 parce qu'on est
sur des lignes qui desservent des
territoires qui sont beaucoup moins
enclins au télétravail ou des des
catégories qui malheureusement ne ne ne
partent moins en congé l'été mais en
vacances pour autant on a justement
cherché dans les plan de transport à
utiliser au maximum toutes les capacités
disponibles et à diversifier ces
capacités par rapport à ce qui se passe
habituellement oui pendant la coupe du
monde de rugby l'essentiel des
spectateurs du Stade de France sont
passés par la ligne 13 et le RERB mais
il y a d'autres lignes qui desservent le
Stade de France il y a le rerd il y aura
la ligne 14 avec une capacité ex
extrêmement importante et puis il y a
aussi la ligne 12 et donc c'est tout
l'enjeu de l'information qui va fait qui
va être faite aux spectateurs qui ne
sont pas deshitués en tout cas pas tous
déh habitués du Stade de France on a
quand même pour les Jeux Olympiques des
spectateurs qui sont très différents de
ceux qui habituellement viennent
viennent voir les les événements ou les
concerts au Stade de France donc on va
vraiment profiter de cette du fait que
ce ce sont en partie des des des des
personnes qui qui ne sont jamais allés
sur ces sites et puis que certains sites
du coup ne ne n'existe pas
habituellement pour vraiment orienter
vers les lignes qui ont la réserve de
capacité donc ça ce sera écrit comme ça
dans les guides spectateurs ce sera
cartographié comme ça et ce sera aussi
fait comme ça dans l'application de
calculateur d'itinéraire c'est-à-dire
que nous allons faire sortir plus
souvent des itinéraires qui empreunent
les lignes à réserve de capacité que
ceux qui utilisent des lignes qui sont
d'habitude surchargé voilà donc c'est
pour ça qu'il sera important d'avoir
vraiment une une forte propor portion de
de spectateurs qui télécharge notre
application et que nous travaillons avec
les autres calculateurs d'itinéraire
pour qu'il rendent qu'ils renvoient les
les mêmes type de de
résultat par ailleurs effectivement je
je je voulais juste préciser concernant
les les personnes en situation du
handicap l'implication d'île-de-fance
mobilité dans la mise en œuvre du schéma
directeur d'accessibilité des
transports nous savons rendre le métro
accessible c'est quelque chose qui est
très compliqué qui ne pourrait être que
de très longues halinees cont tenu de la
complexité des travaux à réaliser nous
avons pour autant aujourd'hui un système
accessible de transport en commun alors
d'abord parce que il n'y a pas que le
métro qui dessert Paris mais il y a
aussi des lignes de RER ces lignes de
RER sont accessibles ce qui veut dire
qu'on a quand même des transports
ferroviaires de à haute capacité à haute
fréquence qui sont accessibles on a
toutes les lignes de tramo qui sont
accessibles on en est à 13 lignes de
tramouis en en île-de-fance enfin 13 la
12e va ouvrir au mois de décembre la 12
parceque la 13 a déjà ouvert avant la 12
euh donc ces lignes de tramoises sont
toutes accessibles elles offre une
desserte de qualité fréquente et qui
permet d'irriguer notamment la
l'approche banlieu et puis le réseau de
bus voilà et donc le réseau de bus à
Paris est entièrement accessible et et
c'est aujourd'hui le support vraiment de
de la dessert pour les personnes en
fauteuil roulant concernant notre
service de navette les réservations vont
ouvrir à partir du mois de janvier ce
qui veut dire que tous les spectateurs
qui ont acheté un billet euh personne en
fauteuil roulant dans un site de paris
2024 vont recevoir un email de la part
de Paris 2024 avec un lien vers la
centrale de réservation voilà donc
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas possible de
réserver mais c'est possible ce sera
possible dès le mois de de janvier enfin
un point qui a été soulevé la question
du couplage entre les billets euh pour
un site de compétition et les titres de
de transport en commun on aurait
souhaité que ce soit possible
malheureusement ça ne l'était pas euh
parce que Paris 2024 en fait va mettre
en place une application dédiée ce
qu'ils appelleent le ticketing c'estàd
que toute la billetterie est sur une
application dédiée qui est complètement
compartimentée en fait pour des raisons
de sécurité euh donc il n'y a aucun lien
possible avec l'application billetterie
euh donc on ne peut pas avoir sur
l'application billetterie en même temps
des titres de transport euh la seule
chose qui est possible effectivement
c'est que Paris 2024 qui connaît par
ailleurs les noms des spectateurs et à
les moyens de les contacter via email ou
via SMS envoie
ou effectivement sur son site internet
et son application il y aura aussi une
application spécifique pour les jeux
pour savoir qui sont les médaillers et
cetera et cetera donc là il y aura de
l'information qui sera donnée pour
télécharger notre application
d'information voyageur et qui sera aussi
donc un un support un support tarifaire
mais techniquement c'était
malheureusement infaisable on aurait
bien aimé que ce soit
possible
merci qui souhaite compléter oui allez-y
Monsieur C merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président Mesdames Messieurs
les les députés donc je vais essayer de
d'apporter quelques précisions par
rapport au réponse des des collègues on
essayons de de ne pas être trop
redondant sur ce qui concerne les les
les plans transport effectivement
l'essentiel des plans transport pour des
sites est bien
stabilisé euh les sujets de qui restent
sensibles sont évidemment les cérémonies
d'ouverture notamment celle de des Jeux
Olympiques qui sont en cours de travail
avec l'ensemble des des parties
prenantes et euh effectivement euh point
d'attention important pour nous la DESC
de la la zone Paris Ouest qui a déjà été
citée et pour laquelle on compte
évidemment non seulement sur les
navettes de bus qui ont été citées euh
précédemment mais également sur
l'ensemble des dispositifs d'information
des voyageurs euh la réussite de la
desserte de ces sites reposant aussi
largement sur la capacité à orienter en
amont les voyageurs dans les modes qui
se qui se leur seront indiqués
préférentiellement pour la desserte de
de ces site
euh le un point d'attention aussi à voir
c'est la vision globale de
l'exploitation de nos lignes puisque
euh non seulement la desserte de chacun
des sites olympiques est essentielle
prise individuellement ce qu'il faut
aussi avoir c'est la vision globale de
l'ensemble de des impacts que qui touche
chacune de nos Nilles et à ce titre le
point que que rappelait madame de brinca
juste avant sur
le les points restants encore affiger
sur les zones de célébration euh est une
un point d'attention pour nous pour
s'assurer de la robustesse des offres
qui pourront être mises en place sur nos
lignes euh comp tenu de l'ampleur ou pas
des flux euh générés par les différents
sites de de
célébration en tout cas euh sur le
le la desserte de la zone dite de Paris
Nord avec j'entends les inquiétudes
quiil avait autour de la ligne 13 il a
été rappelé que certes la ligne 13 est
très fréquentée habituellement et en
plus les jours évidemment de de
compétitions sportives euh et donc il
n'est pas inutile de rappeler que cette
zone euh qui euh aura une densité
importante de lieu olympique euh et
dervis non seulement par les lignes B et
13 du RR et du métro mais euh aussi par
les lignes D et H avec nos amis de de la
SNCF et euh la ligne 12 qui est un petit
peu plus éloignée mais qui présente une
capacité quand même intéressante qui a
déjà été utilisé en renfort de capacité
pour desservir de la zone et surtout
évidemment la la ligne 14 qui apportera
une capacité importante euh et donc je
je précise par rapport à la ligne 14 en
lien avec ce que disait madame Gourlet
tout à l'heure que les essais préalables
à la mise en service de ligne 14 avec le
nouveau système de pilotage automatique
qui équipera se passe bien la
mobilisation de de l'industriel Siemens
auprès des équipes de la RATP de la SGP
l'ensemble des maîtres d'œuvre est bonne
et euh
donc nous sommes confiants pour basculer
la ligne dans le nouveau système au mois
de février prochain en amont des jeux et
donc en amont de l'ouverture des
prolongements à Orly et playel
euh sur le je je complète le le le point
sur le l'accompagnement des personnes en
situation de de
handicap sans revenir sur les sujets de
de l'accessibilit ilité
euh moteur euh qui ont été évoqué je
tiens à souligner que euh il est
également essentiel de prendre en compte
les autres types de handicap visuel ou
auditif par exemple euh et que à ce
titre- là la RATP comme les autres
opérateurs de transport et avec
î-defance mobilité évidemment nous
sommes très mobilisés et nous avons
signé avec le
le les les représentants de l'État une
un plan d'action pour l'amélioration de
du traitement des différents types de
handicap en vu des Jeux Olympiques qui
prend en
compte notamment l'amélioration du
l'accompagnement des situations de
handicap visuel ou auditif et euh
également tout un plan de formation du
personnel de renforcement des
compétences qui existe déjà puisque
l'accompagnement humain des personnes en
situation de handicap est aussi un
élément
essentiel dans le
le le les
possibilités offerte aux personnes
handicapées de de se déplacer donc à ce
titre là je rappelle que l'ensemble du
personnel de la RTP est formé et
notamment les agents du réseau F les
5000 agents d'accueil du réseau ferré
sont tous certifiés capando
et d'ici les jeux l'ensemble de nos
volontaires à RATP bénéficieront
également de sessions de formation pour
correctement accompagner ce dispositif
humain de traitement de situation de
handicap
euh un mot sur le les questions sociales
qui étaient posées donc les
discussions sociales les négociations à
l'
RATP en vue de l'accompagnement des jeux
ont démarré depuis la fin de l'été à ce
stade il y a eu une soixantaine
d'audiences qui se sont déroulé dans
l'entreprise avec les différentes
organisations syndicales
représentatives pour évoquer le sujet et
anticiper l'ensemble des points qui
mérite de l'être donc notamment dans ces
discussions il y a évidemment le sujet
des congés en période estival
euh pour certaines catégories de
personnel évidemment la préparation des
Jeux et la mobilisation du personnel
nécessite de travailler sur des grilles
de d'attribution de place de congé un
petit peu différentes de la période
habituel ça veut pas dire que il y a pas
de congés qui seront attribués en
période estivale ça veut dire qu'ils
seront attribués différ apparemment et
il faut l'anticiper le prendre en compte
dans ces discussions sociales sont
également évoqué les contraintes qui
s'appliqueront aux différents métiers de
l'entreprise donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle les négociation se passent à
plusieurs niveaux simultanément et de
manière coordonnée d'une part d'un point
de vue transversal à l'entreprise pour
assurer la cohérence de
l'ensemble du dispositif euh et euh
traiter les questions qui se posent de
manière commune entre les directions et
euh à un niveau décentralisé au nivu de
chacune des directions pour bien prendre
en compte les contraintes spécifiques de
chacun des métiers euh et les
organisations spécifiques qui devront
être adapté pendant les Jeux par exemple
euh pour les agents qui compte tenu des
contraintes de circulation devrait êre
amener à euh changer d'attachement
géographique par exemple temporairement
euh euh ou à à à prendre en compte des
contraintes organisationnelles sur sur
leur métier donc ces discussions sont en
cours euh elle se passe dans un esprit
tout à fait constructif le personnel de
la RATP a évidemment envie que les jeux
qui se passent une fois par siècle à
Paris soit une réussite euh et donc on
ces négociations se passent jusqu'à
présent dans un bon esprit et euh nous
espérons euh arriver à conclure le sujet
d'ici la fin d'année en amont en
particulier de l'attribution euh des euh
des grilles de congé pour les personnels
les catégories de personnels qui sont
concernés merci est-ce que parmi les
orateurs d'autres souhaitent s'exprimer
non benah peut-être pour SNCF très
rapidement parce que beaucoup de choses
ont été dites sur les plans de transport
euh l'essentiel a été stabilisé
effectivement nous traitons les points
particuliers tel que la cérémonie
d'ouverture ou les adaptations d'horair
en fonction de la façon dont
l'organisateur prévoit en fait et adapte
en fait son son événement et notre
événement je citerai quand même le
travail que nous menons de concert avec
le ministère de l'Éducation nationale et
puis la délégation interministériel des
Jeux Olympiques sur le transport des
scolaires je l'ai dit dans mon propos
liminaire pendant la première semaine
des Jeux paralympiques nous faisons un
travail assez fin de fourmis puisqu'il
s'agit de groupes dont il faut qu'on
nous garantissions évidemment leur
transport depuis l'ensemble des
territoires vers Paris euh le plan de
transport nous amène à parler de la
sécurisation des ressources et je veux
bien apporter un complément par rapport
aux questions qui ont été posées sur le
calendrier social nous sommes
complètement en adéquation entre les
ressources et la mobilisation du
personnel par rapport au services à
délivrer pour les Jeux Olympiques et
Paralympiques euh il y a quatre types de
métiers finalement qui sont prignants
dans cet événement ce sont les agents de
conduite les agents de la Sûreté les
agents en fait des G gestionnaire
d'infrastructure de SNCF réseau ou
l'accueil en gare et nous avons activé
plusieurs leviers pour nous permettre
d'avoir cette adéquation charge
ressources le premier étant d'avoir des
recrutements qui étaient parfois
anticipés c'est le cas notamment des
agents de la Sûreté ferroviaire avec 400
recrutements qui ont été faits entre en
2022 2023 et 150 qui sont faits cette
année en anticipation de manière à à
avoir le maximum de ressources
disponibles au moment des jeux et qui
ensuite bien évidemment resteront euh
forcément
dans dans dans l'entreprise pour
poursuivre leur mission le deuxième
levier c'est évidemment les congés euh
nous avons besoin de toutes les
ressources qui nécessite d'avoir des des
adaptations des périodes de congé j'y
reviendrai dans le dialogue social le
troisème levier c'est pour SNC fréo
c'est tout à fait technique en fait je
l'ai dit dans mon propos liminaire
également nous libérons en fait de la
capacité ferroviaire pour avoir le
maximum de sillons ce qui rejoint en
fait notre capacité à réaliser le plan
de transport en ne faisant pas et en ne
réalisant pas les travaux pendant cette
période B il se trouve que les
ressources qui habituellement font les
travaux seront mobilisées pour traiter
être sur des permanences pour intervenir
en cas d'incidence qui répond aussi à
une question une contrainte de
d'amélioration de l'efficacité de notre
couverture de des incidents qui qui
pourront se produire fa avoir conscience
voilà donc on se mobilise sur ces
incidents pour avoir ça enfin le dernier
levier c'est notre programme de
volontariat pour l'accueil en gare où il
s'agit simplement de nous avons lancé un
appel à volontariat et nous nous l'avons
relancé massivement notamment pour
inciter évidemment les les les salariés
des sièges de donner le un petit coup de
pouce he sur dans les gares quoi pour
assurer une présence humaine plus
forte comme nous le faisons avec les
gilets rouges comme que vous connaissez
bien évidemment lorsque nous avons des
pics de grands départ par exemple sur
les pointes de neige ou les pointes
d'été le dialogue social il est il est
en cours il y a deux tablees rondes qui
sont organisés ce fois-ci le 23 novembre
et le 28 novembre et des bilatérales qui
sont organisés avec avec les
organisations syndicales représentatives
du personnel cela porte ce dialogue
social sur des mesures congé qui ont
déjà été définis qui sont des mesures
incitatives où on gère techniquement la
façon dont les congés peuvent être
portés pris pendant cette période avec
quelques compensations bien évidemment
les discussions portent aussi sur les
compensations par
rapport voilà à une un effort qui est
réalisé par bah cette adaptation des
congés c'est normal en fait que c'est
voilà que a des compensations qui qui
soit discuté dans ce cadre là donc je
peux pas vous en dire plus parce que les
discussions sont sont en cours et j'ai
annoncé des dates qui seraient plutôt à
la fin du mois donc irons barement plus
clair d'ici la fin de l'année sur
l'accessibilité il a été dit beaucoup de
choses moi je signifierais simplement
pour SNCF que nous avons environ 60
gares qui sont directement concernés par
l'accessibilité des sites olympiques et
que bah ces gar sont tout accessibles
parce que ça faisait partie d'un
engagement lors de la candidature du
groupe SNCF d'avoir neu gares mise en
service pour fiabiliser l'ensemble de
ces de ce dispositif dans le cadre du du
schéma directeur exibilité cité de
France mobilité qui qui finance ce ce
schéma directeur d' accessibilité nous
avons rajouté la Gard de Saint-Denis euh
qui permet d'avoir une accessibilité
depuis la ligne et au-delà de ces
infrastructures nous avons mené aussi
des diagnostics sur l'ensemble des
équipements que ce soit visuel auditif
et et nous avons établi un plan de
fiabilisation de de ces équipements y
compris ascenseur escalier mécanique euh
les navettes UFR ça sera évidemment euh
le service qui sera privilégié euh bah
pour l'accès au site parce que c'est
comme ça que l'information sera poussée
comme l'a dit Laurence de Branca auprès
des détenteurs de billets qui sont en
situation de handicap mais bien
évidemment le réseau sera tout à fait en
capacité d'accueillir l'ensemble des euh
des psage PMR et comme comme la RATP et
comme Aéroport de Paris nous sommes
engagés au travers de la charte signée
dans le cadre du dernier comité
interministériel du handicap et nousous
avons évidemment de deux actions
complémentaires par rapport à cell que
j'ai cité que sont les renforts
d'assistance ce sont des prestataires
don qui savent d'or et déjà en fait
qu'il y aura un renfort sorte de
surbooking en fait de ces ressources
dans lesgard pour assurer les les
besoins supplémentaires et nous faisons
de évidemment de l'analyse au cas par
cas et enfin la mise en place d'une
plateforme unique de réservation et
d'une information spécifique lié en fait
à cet outil qui va simplifier cette
plateforme unique de réservation va
permettre d'avoir un seul point d'entrée
pour les personnes en situation handicap
pour faire leur réservation de
l'assistance dans les transports alors
que auparavant il y en avait plusieurs
chaque enfin chaque chaque transporteur
avait sa propre son propre service de
réservation tout ça va être centralisé
c'est quelque chose qui était prévu dans
la loi d'orientation des mobilité que
nous mettrons en application pour le 10
janvier
2024 merci beaucoup je vous propose de
passer aux questions d'une minute il y a
pas d'autres interventions questions
d'une minute posée par Madame Cécile
riaac merci monsieur le président madame
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs à
moins d'un an j'ai des Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques de 2024 la question de
savoir si l'on pourra facilement se
déplacer en île-de-fance pendant la
compétition et sur toutes les lèves de
tous les usagers franiliens des
transports en commun je pense bien sûr
au cœur de la capitale et son accès mais
également aux habitants de la banlieue
parisienne et notamment de ma
circonscription du valdoise qui tout au
long de l'année sont fréquemment
confronté à des perturbations sur le
rerc la ligne H et la ligne J qui relie
le valdoise notamment au centre de Paris
mais aussi qui nous relie à Saint-Denis
ou à saint-toin vous le savez des
chantiers de grande ampleur ont été
lancés pour accroître notre offre de
transport durant cet événement
planétaire tous les aménagements prévus
seront-ils réalisés avant le début de la
compétition je pense à un petit peu à
l'interconnexion de Saint-Denis pleel
que ce soit pour les spectateurs des
différentes épreuves pour l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens qui continueront leur
déplacement habituel tout au long de la
période ou pour les personnes à mobilité
réduite qui seront confronté à la hausse
de l'affluence dans les transports en
commun il faut garantir une offre de
transport suffisante et adapté vous nous
avez répondu vous avez répondu à ma
question concernant ces défis j'en aurai
une simplement sur les dessertes des
taxis aux alentours du stade de
Saint-Denis aujourd'hui ils ne peuvent
pas nous y amener et nous y récupérer
merci madame la députée merci la parole
est à Sophie
blanc merci Monsieur le le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les zones de
tarification RATP ne sont facilement
compréhensibles ni très lisibles par
tous nos concitoyens cette grille de
facturation fine devient rapidement
totalement opaque pour des personnes
étrangères pouvez-vous pensez-vous
éditer des billets Joo simples et
lisibles qui éviteront aux spectateurs
de se voir infiger des amendes pour
n'avoir pasompris que Saint-Denis
n'était pas à Paris par exemple je vous
remercie merci la parole est à Danielle
brûlebois merci monsieur le Président ma
question peut-être hors sujet puisque
l'objet de notre table ronde est le
transport des voyageurs qui implique un
plan de circulation mais je souhaite me
faire le relais des inquiétudes de nos
entreprises pour l'activité économique
elles aimeraient avoir des précisions
sur les zonages en cinq niveaux en terme
de périmètrre et de contrainte c'est
ainsi que la cimenterie équium du Jura
s'interroge sur l'impact des plans de
circulation sur ses activités
spécifiques de livraison de matériaux de
construction nous savons qu'un large
périmètre sera concerné par le plus haut
niveau de protection donc il est
légitime que nos entreprises
s'inquiètent sur une éventuelle
paralysie de leur activité durant 3 mois
et sur les cons que cela implique en
terme de chiffre d'affaires et bien sûr
d'emploi je pense qu'il est nécessaire
de rassurer le monde
économique qui s'inquiète sur un leur
chantier qui risque d'être stoppé et
donc beaucoup d'entreprises auront du
mal à passer le
cap merci la parole est à sylvien
carrière merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames Messieurs les goop de Paris
approchent et l'accessibilité reste des
grands oubliés de la politique menée
moins de 10 % des stations de métro sont
accessibles les navettes sur demande
proposées ne desserviront que les grands
pôles de transport que sont les gares
SNCF dont l'accès ne pourra se faire
qu'en RER ou en bus comment se passera
donc l'accès à ces transports pour les
personnes en fauteuil dans un contexte
de
surfréquentation aussi dans un dans un
sondage de l'APF France handicap de 2020
Paris n'était jugé accessible que par 19
% des sondés notamment au vu de la
largeur des trottoirs ou de l'accès aux
ERP l'accessibilité ne se juge pas
uniquement aux équipements dans les
transports en commun mais bien dans tous
les déplacements notamment ceux au sein
d'une ville dès lors qu'a-t-il été
entrepris afin de rendre Paris et les
villes hautes plus accessibles qu'elle
ne l'était en 2019 l'inaccessibilité est
la première des inégalités profitons des
jop pour faire une grande campagne sur
les retards en terme d'accessibilité je
vous remercie merci la parole est à
Emmanuel
Antoine
oui merci monsieur le Président je
souhaiterais revenir sur
l'accessibilité pendant les Jeux le
nombre de spectateurs en situation de
handicap attendu par jour est estimé à
4000 or l'offre de transport adapté
risque de se révéler insuffisante la
problématique ancienne que représente la
difficulté du réseau de transport
collectif francilien à se mettre en
conformité contenu de l'ancienneté des
lignes n'a pas été résolu par
l'organisation des Jeux l'engagement
d'accessibilité ne pourra ainsi pas être
être tenu sauf à prendre des mesures
alternatives au transport en commun ce
constat grave pourrait représenter un
véritable échec pour l'ambition
d'inclusivité des jobs 2024 la
contrainte de devoir recourir au taxis
crée de l'exclusion pour les personnes
les moins aisés du fait du coût plus
important que représente ce mode de
transport en outre le parc des taxis
adaptés aux personnes à mobilité réduite
et celui du réseau d' à la mobilité
resteront insuffisants pour répondre à
la demande vous nous avez esquissé
certaines propositions i mais
pensez-vous et pouvez-vous nous assurer
que ces dispositifs pourront répondre
aux besoins de transport des 4000
personnes attendues en situation de
handicap et un transport de
qualité merci la parole est à Damien
Adam merci monsieur le Président je
voudrais moi aussi revenir sur le sujet
du déplacement des personnes en
situation de handicap pendant les Jeux
Olympiques j'ai bien pris note de la
mise en place d'un service de navette
pour compléter l'offre de transport afin
de répondre aux besoins spécifiques des
personnes la mobilité réduite notamment
en fauteuil quelle sera la politique
tarifaire pour ces navettes seront-elles
accessibles pour le prix d'un ticket de
métro ou avec le passe Navigo 2è sujet
vous avez fait le choix de créer une
distorsion de concurrence entre taxi et
VTC en fixant un objectif de 1000 taxis
accessible tris FO trois à quatre fois
plus par rapport à la flotte
d'aujourd'hui et la mise en place d'une
aide financière à l'acquisition pourquoi
ne pas avoir ouvert cette possibilité à
l'ensemble des acteurs de transport
public particulier de personnes enfin
j'ai une question sur la dépose des
personnes à mobilité réduite sur les
sites de compétition que ce soit avec
une navette un taxi ou un VTC les
personnes seront-elles déposées au plus
près des entrées des sites y compris à
l'intérieur des périmètres fermés à la
circulation je vous remercie merci la
parole est à Isabelle
perériigot merci monsieur le Président
chers collègues Mesdames et Messieurs
les les intervenants je reviens
également sur l'accessibilité les
organisateurs de Paris 2024 ont bien sûr
à cœur de faire des Jeux paralympiques
qu'un événement qui puisse promouvoir
l'inclusivité d'ailleurs quasiment tous
les sites de compétition hein seront
identiques entre les jeux paralympiqu et
olympique excepté pour les épreuves sur
route alors selon l'association APF he
France handicap anciennement association
des paralisé de France 80 % des
personnes en situation de handicap sont
atteintes d'un handicap invisible ce qui
représente 9 millions de personnes en
France ma collègue l'a dit tout à
l'heure lors de ces jeux nous attendons
au moins 4000 athlètes et près de 350000
visiteurs en situation de handicap qui
sont attendu il était énoncé la mise en
acéité de 240 stations de métro sur 309
d'ici 2024 néanmoins selon les
associations seulement 45 seront
accessibles alors ma question est simple
justifiez-vous ce chiffre et qu'est-il
prévu pour permettre au touriste en
situation de handicap de se rendre sur
les lieu de compétition je vous
remercie merci la parole est à Hubert
buulfran merci monsieur le Président oui
juste une une une interrogation euh il y
a des périmètres il y a des territoires
en en couronne provinciale je pense il
le rouand par exemple hein enfin
Normandie euh et bien ça va être des des
des territoires à la fois de de
résidence de de touristes parce que comp
tenu des prix en RP il y en a qui vont
pas hésiter à aller à à 100 150 bornes
pour pour pour trouver du logement et ça
va être aussi des des périmètres où où
les gens vont vont aller se balader ils
sont à Paris mais on pourra forcément y
rester euh c'est des lieux touristiques
Normandie et cetera P de Loire il y en a
d'autres j'imagine donc je voulais je
voulais savoir si notamment au niveau de
nos nos nos trains là vous aviez pris en
compte ces déplacements qui vont être
des déplacements induits notamment sur
les liaisons Intercité en avec des
ajustements peut-être moins d'attrition
dans les euh dans dans dans dans les
déplacements tel que c'est régulièrement
prévu donc dans en en période de
vacances parce que on est dans des
déplacements pendulaires évidemment
beaucoup moindres mais quand
même merci la parole est à hugette
tigna merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et
Messieurs notamment les représentant de
RTP et de
SNCF donc quand on se déplace de depuis
le lodre jusqu'à Paris euh notamment des
fija qui nous faut à moyenne 7h pour
rejoindre Paris et comme vous le savez
pendant ces jeux c'est aussi l'occasion
pour le monde rural de venir voir et
apprécier la qualité des jeux du sport
voir d'y participer euh aujourd'hui
au-delà de ces secturs cont tenu des des
changements des supression de trains on
peut aller jusqu'à 12h d'étranger pour
rejoindre Paris pouvez-vous nous dire si
ces contraintes seront encore plus
augmentées pendant les jeux ou alors
avez-vous des moyens de nous rassurer je
vous
remercie merci la parole est à Pascal
Boyer merci monsieur le Président les
Jeux Olympiques et paraolympique 2024
seront un très bel événement sportif
planétaire nous n'en doutons pas la la
réussite de ces jeux permettra d'aborder
sereinement la préparation des Jos 2030
qui se dérouleront également en France
dans les Alpes français et cela non plus
nous n'en doutons pas ma question porte
sur le défraimement de nombreux
bénévoles qui se seront engagés dans
l'organisation des gios Paris 2024 à
quelle hauteur seront-ils effrayés aussi
bien sur les lieux où se dérouleront les
événements sportifs que dans les
territoires labellisés terre de jeu 2024
des territoires parfois éloignés des
lieux où se dérouleront les épreuves je
pense notamment à mon département les
Hautes Alpes qui sera la base arrière et
qui accueillera trois sites de
préparation pour les athlètes des sport
d'au viv du VTT et de l'escalade je vous
remercie merci la parole est à gu
brigou merci monsieur le président étant
un Ardon défenseur du mode fluvial
j'aimerais savoir si vous pensez
l'utiliser au moment des jeux notamments
l'installation de navettes sur la scène
sur le site VNF on peut notamment lire
durant les Jeux la scène offrira
également des solutions innovantes de
transport de frê et de passagers pour
faire vivre l'événement logistique du
village et des événements stockage sur
l'eau de matériel bateau à passagers où
on estant concrètement de ces
perspectives et toujours dans l'original
des capsules urban loop véhicules
autonomes sur rail seront mis en service
pour ces Jeux Olympiques nous atttons
dit ce dont on peut se féliciter ce
projet qui est né dans une école
d'ingénieurs de l'Université de Loren
est une belle vitrine de transport bon
pour la planète combien de personnes
permettront-elle de transporter sur quel
tronçon exactement peut-on espérer que
ce bel exemple permette aussi
d'accélérer le développement du véhicule
autonome dans les années à venir dans
notre pays
merci merci la parole est à Francis
Dubois merci monsieur le Président
madames messieurs les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques 2024 devraent accueillir
près de 13,5 millions de visiteurs et
plus de 15000 à tête le succès de cette
fête mondiale passe par une gestion
réussie de l'accueil des visiteurs et
des y compris dans les transports se
pose donc la question de l'accessibilité
des transports durant ces Jeux pour les
personnes à mobilité réduite selon la
EPE France handicap 350000 spectateurs
handicapés assisteront à ces jeux or
d'après les données d'île-de France
mobilité seulement 9 % du métro
actuellement accessiblebl aux personnes
à mobilité réduite il y a pourtant été
annoncé que 268 gares SNCF et stations
de métro devrai être rendu accessible en
Île-de-France qu'en est-il donc à moins
de 9 mois de cet événement quelle
solution alternative proposez-vous
s'agissant des handicaps visuels et
auditifs un plan pour améliorer
l'accessibilité sonore et visuelle est
également prévu où en eston de son
déploiement et pourriez-vous nous en
préciser le contenu enfin ont-il
envisagé de poursuivre les efforts
entrepris pour améliorer l'accessibilité
des transports pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite au-delà de la période
des jop je vous remercie d'une réponse
pragmatique merci à l'image de toutes
les réponses qui ont été apportées
jusque là il me semble la parole est à
Jean-Pierre tê oui merci monsieur le
Président chers collègues le comité
d'organisation des j de Paris 2024 a
promis que tous les stades et sites
olympique serait accessible à vélo
malgré 55 km d'olympiste restant réalisé
d'ici l'année prochaine il semble que
l'objectif ne sera pas atteint combien
de kilomètres reste-t-il à réaliser et
combien manqueront l'héritage en piste
cyclable permettra-t-il de développer la
pratique du vélo et d'offrir des
itinéraires intéressants pour des
trajets domicile travail enfin n'y
a-t-il pas eu des effets d'obè en terme
de captation de subvention notamment sur
le plan vélo au détriment d'équipement
indispensable aménageable dans le reste
de la France mon département de la Loire
et notamment le forêt en ont bien besoin
enfin sur les sur les vélos toujours la
hausse du nombre de vélibles à Paris de
18000 à 21000 et l'effort promis par les
loueurs sera-t-il suffisant pour
satisfaire la demande éventuelle je vous
remercie
merci est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
questions chers collègues pas d'autres
questions monsieur pardon je vous laisse
le soin de de répondre et puis par la
suite si vous voulez compléter c'est
avec
plaisir très bien merci un premier point
peut-être pour revenir sur les questions
fluviales qui ont été évoqué à plusieurs
reprises d'abord pour vous dire que à
l'occasion des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques il y a un engagement qui a
été pris sur le Fluvia pour verdir la
flotte qui qui navigue sur la scène avec
un engagement
de de d'une trentaine de de navires
enfin de bateaux qui vont être convertis
avec des motorisations propres donc ça
c'est c'est un engagement qui qui sera
tenu hein donc les les travaux sont sont
en cours et également sur le la desserte
pluviale lors de d'un appel à
manifestation d'intérêt pour des des
projets innovants euh trois trois
projets qui ont été pris dont dont un un
dans les sones et un sur sur Bordeaux
également de manière à promouvoir
euh le transport fluvial autonome et
propre pour selon les les différentes
caractéristiques de ces de ces trois
trois lauréat de de l'appel à projet euh
je reviens aussi évidemment sur
l'accessibilité aux personnes en
situation de handicap qui a été évoqué
par par beaucoup d'entre
vous d'abord peut-être sur les sur les
chiffres autour des des gares et des des
stations de métro
accessibles je pense que que les
chiffres qui ont été avancés sont le
cumulle des stations de métro et des
gares du réseau de la
SNCF aujourd'hui les les deux lignes de
RER A et B sont accessibles donc toutes
les gares sont sont accessibles et par
ailleurs le schéma directeur
d'accessibilité qui est sous l'autorité
d'Al de France
mobilité et qui est déployé depuis 2000
9 2011 les deux les deux dates clés de
de cette définition du schéma directeur
d'accessibilité a permis la mise en
accessibilité de garees du réseau SNCF
sur lesqueles d'ailleurs est revenu tout
à l'heure tout à l'heure la SNCF donc
l'ensemble des gares utile pour les Jeux
Olympiques la soixantaine de gares qu'a
évoqué Jonathan duriux tout à l'heure
sera mise en accessibilité et elles le
sont pour la plupart d'ors et déjà les
mises en service sont continues presque
alors peut-être pas chaque semaine mais
en tout cas très régulièrement plusieurs
par mois en ce moment pour pour mettre à
niveau d'accessibilité le réseau
ferroviaire pour ce qui concerne le
reste du réseau comme vous l' indiqué
tout à l'heure madame de brinca
euh justement dans le schéma directeur
d'accessibilité qui avait été qui avait
été défini c'est bien le réseau de
surface donc le réseau de bus le réseau
de tramou euh pour le pour Paris Paris
Centre et sa sa proche couronne qui a
été euh mis en accessibilité décidé de
mettre en accessibilité comp tenu des
difficultés sur le le métro historique
donc le l'ensemble du réseau de
transport existant est réputé accessible
au titre de l'accessibilité du réseau de
surface d'une part et des efforts qui
sont déployés par la RATP et par la SNCF
pour la mise en accessibilité des gares
sur le réseau ferrovière donc RA RRB
sont accessibles ligne 14 sera à 100 %
accessible et et pour le reste c'est
évidemment le réseau de surface qui peut
qui peut prendre qui peut prendre le
relais
euh
j'ajoute peut-être pour le pour le
redire de nouveau qu'à l'occasion des
Jeux euh il y a deux deux mesures
spécifiques qui sont prises celles sur
les navettes qui sont une mesure
temporaire pour les jeux donc des
navettes accessibles pour les personnes
munies d'un billet qui vont pouvoir
réserver cette navette pour se rendre
sur le sur les sites de compétition et
une navette et une pardon une mesure
dite d'héritage sur les taxis
accessibles le plan 1 taxis que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure euh l'idée c'était
de se servir du levier des Jeux
Olympiques pour augmenter la flotte de
taxis accessible disponible et c'est
évidemment une mesure qui va perdurer
dans le temps
euh et enfin sur ce point particulier
aussi nous sommes sur chaque site en
train de regarder très précisément les
lieux de dépose des taxis et en
particulier euh des taxis qui euh euh
transporteront des personnes à mobilité
réduite pour que les lieux de dépose
soient au plus près des sites de
compétition donc pour ces pour ces
véhiculeslà les véhicules les véhicules
des personnes à mobilité réduite ils
pourront euh ils pourront s'approcher au
plus près et et et accéder aux zones de
de restriction de circulation de manière
à déposer évidemment les les personnes
notamment qui ont des difficultés
moteures
euh au plus près du site de compétition
donc ça c'est c'est bien pris en compte
et c'est étudié site par site euh en
lien entre l'organisateur Paris 2024 et
la préfecture de
police revenir aussi sur le les mesures
relatives au plans de circulation par
rapport au tissus économiqu euh donc les
différents plans de circulation ils
seront ils seront annoncés dans les dans
les prochaines semaines par la
préfecture de police il est certain que
les mesures elles
sont à la fois d'abord d'ordre
sécuritaire pour sécuriser les sites
mais aussi proportionné pour permettre
pour permettre la circulation notamment
des véhicules des professionnels et en
particulier du du bâtiment et du du
génie
civil donc ça c'est c'est une donnée
d'entrée que la préfecture de police a
prise en compte dans la définition de
ces différents
périmètres
eu je voulais également revenir sur la
les territoires voisins
d'Île-de-France où en lien avec les
différentes autorités organisatrices
régionales la SNCF travaille bien sûr
euh au travers de son activité TER à des
renforts selon selon les régions
ponctuelles et selon les demandes euh et
les analyses menées par les autorités
organisatrices des transports dans les
différentes régions enfin peut-être sur
Urban loop qui a été mentionné tout à
l'heure donc urban loop c'est un
démonstrateur euh qui sera mis en œuvre
sur la base de loisirs de 50 ans en
Yveline donc c'est l'occasion des Jeux
qui est pris pour mettre 9 ce
démonstrateur c'est un projet qui est
lauréa là aussi de d'un appel à
manifestation d'intérêt euh porté par
porté par l'État et par la DGITM donc
c'est vraiment le l'occasion de de
démontrer ce ce savoir-faire il ne fait
pas partie du plan de transport en tant
que tel des Jeux Olympiques il y a un
site d'expérimentation qui a été choisi
à à sur la base de loisir de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline voilà sur les
différentes
questions peut-être si d'autres
personnes souhaitent prendre la parole
vous en prie oui en en complément euh il
y avait une question concernant la
tarification donc nous avons prévu
pendant les Jeux Olympiques et
paralympique de mettre en place un
forfait Paris 2024 euh donc ce forfait
sera euh permettra de d'utiliser les
transports en commun dans l'ensemble du
réseau de de transport en commun il sera
pas zoné comme les certains titres
actuellement euh donc ça simplifiera
évidemment la la vie des des spectateurs
et il sera disponible pour différentes
euh duré hein 1 jour 2 jours 3 jours 5
jours et cetera euh donc ça c'est c'est
c'est effectivement pour cette
tarification général quant au services
de navettes euh effectivement euh on va
mettre en place un tarif spécifique pour
pour ces navettes pour les personnes en
fauteuil roulant euh qui sera modique
voilà donc le tarif sera fixé par notre
conseil d'administration euh mais dans
tous les cas ce sera ce sera un tarif
modique pour un service euh qui sera
quand même de de de qualité donc euh il
n'aura rien à voir avec un un tarif de
de taxi ou de ou de
VTC euh voilà et donc nous ne prévoyons
pas de de de navette fluvial en en
transport en commun sur la scène
effectivement euh il y a des réflexions
qui sont en cours a de France mobilité
de de manière générale pour développer
le le transport le transport fluvial
c'est quelque chose qui est assez
complexe parce que les conditions de de
navigation notamment dans le bief de
Paris sont sont quand même extrêmement
contraintes en terme de vie vitesse
potentielle des des navettes et et donc
les les projets qui sont plutôt
aujourd'hui envisagé serait plutôt sur
sur le canal de l'Ourc ou en dehors du
du bief de Paris sur la scène voilà mais
mais effectivement de manière ce ne sera
pas mis en place pendant les Jeux euh où
en revancheah circuleront sur la scène
les les les Batobus habituels et et puis
il y aura certainement beaucoup de
services
touristiques peut-être pour la la isncf
oui alors sur l'accessibilité j'ai déjà
répondu à pas mal de choses dans dans
les questions précédentes je peux
simplement il y a un point quand même
qui a été soulevé là qui est comment en
fait une personne euh en situation de
handicap qu'elle soit utilisat enfin
utilisatrice de fauteuil roulant ou tout
simplement d'autres handicaps sont pas
forcément visibles Ben se s'orientent
dans la foule hein dans les dans les
dans les flux euh donc bah pour celles
qui n'utiliseraient pas les navettes UFR
euh euh je je peux simplement souligner
que j'ai parlé de notre programme de de
de volontariat nos volontaires en fait
tout comme les personnels SNCF qui sont
formés en fait à à je dirais aux
spécificités aux besoins spécifiques en
fait des personnes en situation de
handicap seront sensibilisés au travers
de modules de de e-learning sur bah sur
ces sur ces question de manière à avoir
un regard avoir voilà très très proactif
j'ai envie de dire enfin en tout cas
d'être très attentif à ce type de
situation de manière à les repérer et
puis de d'aller vers en fait bah ces
personnes qui en auraiit besoin et enfin
nous nous allons mettre en place dans la
gestion des flux euh des gromes pour
l'accès au train qui permettra de
prioriser l'accès en fait aux personnes
en situation de handicap en fauteuil
roulant pour l'accès pour l'accès au
train tout simplement donc
prépositionner notamment sur les quaiis
et sur les espaces devant les ascenseurs
par exemple pour que euh il y a vraiment
une priorisation qui soit faite par
rapport à ce public ça c'est quelque
chose que nous regardons que nous
regardons aussi de manière de concert
aussi avec évidemment RATP ou Paris 2024
puisque bah ces problématiques qui
existent dans les transports existent
bien évidemment enfin en tout cas CCF
partout sur
l'accès des territoires en terme de
transport Florent Bardon l'a dit en fait
on a on a trois types de de transport
enfin va dire même quatre trois types de
transport euh bah qui sont qui
permettent d'accéder à à Paris ce sont
les TER sous l'autorité des
organisatrices des autorités
organisatrices régionales donc les
régions avec qui nous sommes en
discussion et qui sont toutes enment
informé de la façon dont se déroul les
jeux euh des discussions sont en cours
dans un cadre dans ce cadre
contractuel nous ferons le service en
fait qui nous sera demandé de réaliser
euh nous avons l'autorité organisatrice
inter état pour
Intercité même sujet nous regardons là
plus particulièrement l'accès de châurou
qui est une ville une ville haute en
terme d'horaire pour voir ce qui est
faisable enfin plutôt acceptable aussi
en terme d'horaire il s'agit de il
s'agit aussi de mettre des services qui
soient utiles et qui et qui engendre une
bonne expérience voyageur de pas les
faire venir trop tard euh dans la nuit
ou partir trop tôt parce que bon il faut
que ça soit quand même une expérience
sympathique les jeux euh et puis ensuite
nous avons le TGV c'est pour ça que j'ai
dit 4 on a les accès évidemment euh des
de nos filiales
Eurostar Lyia euh bah de depuis
l'international sur bah sur Paris qui
sont bah évidemment des offres grande
vitesse et puis nous avons les TGV alors
ça pour le coup c'est SNCF qui est euh à
la manœuvre euh nous nous allons
utiliser le maximum de notre parc
euh TGV de nos moyens humains et qui
seront mis à disposition faitement des
transports pendant les jeux sur ces
différentes
liaisons j'en profite pour dire qu'il
n'y aura pas en fait de dérogation enfin
de de dégradation en fait du service
puisque le moratoire de travaux nous
protège aussi et c'est une des raisons
pour laquelle on on l'appliquer de de ne
pas avoir en fait d'incidence de de
retard li à des travaux qui sont
nécessaires en temps habituel évidemment
sur le sur le réseau donc P dans cette
période c'est ce qui nous permet de
d'avoir le maximum d'efficacité de des
lignes telles que nous permettent de
transporter voyageurs avec les temps les
temps les temps drapeau hein les temps
de parcours drapeau
euh sur donc c TGV euh en sur ces offres
on va dire territoriales on il faut
avouer quand même qu'on a du mal à
appréhender mais on sait que comment les
mobilités vont vont évoluer pendant
cette période euh c'est tout à fait
logique il est possible que les
personnes qui habituellement partaient
en vacances pendant cette période ben
décident de rester tout simplement parce
qu'elles ont elles ont des billets pour
assister aux épreuves au contraire
décide d'anticiper le le leur retard qu'
des flux comme vous l'avez souligné
régionaux vers Paris pendant cette péode
qu'il faut prendre en compte on a du mal
à appréhender mais on le fait on le fait
avec Paris 2024 puisque Paris 2024 a
accès au aux données des des des régions
qui ont acheté des des billets euh alors
ça veut pas dire que ce sont les les
personnes qui vont qui ont acheté
billement qui vont être présents mais
tout ça c'est choses qui se font au fil
de l'eau euh un mail a été envoyer
d'ailleurs à l'ensemble des détenteurs
de Bill cette semaine pour leur demander
quel serait leur pratique de mobilité
donc ça ce sont des informations qui
sont importantes qui vont nous nourrir
et puis lorsque pour TGV nous allons
ouvrir en fait les réservations nous
serons aussi en situation d'observation
pour voir comment en fait les
réservations se font à quelle période
pour bien mieux mieux appréhender et
mieux adapter notre offre si besoin euh
voilà voilà j'espère que j'ai répondu à
vos
questions pour la RATP je vous en
prie merci monsieur le Président
j'apporterai juste un un petit
complément pour sur la partie
accessibilité pour donner quelques
éléments de détail qui qui étaient
demander notamment sur la prise en
charge des le contenu du du du plan
d'action sur le traitement des
situations en terme de handicap visuel
ou auditif euh donc je vourrais
simplement rappeler que euh l'ensemble
des
sujets liés à la prise en charge du
handicap sont évoqués régulièrement en
comité consultatif d'accessibilité euh à
l' RATP présidé par Jean Castex le sujet
est également régulièrement évoqué lors
du comité stratégique des mobilités euh
en présence des ministres et en comité
interministériel du du handicap euh dans
le plus précisément dans le plan
d'action sur le traitement des handicaps
la amélioration du tritement du handicap
visuel auditif on peut citer notamment
le déploiement de manchon en braille euh
dans les stations de métro euh le
développement euh en lien avec
île-de-fance mobilité euh de de
solutions de de de guidage une
application
euh pour le le guidage des personnes en
situation de de handicap dans nos
espaces
euh on a plusieurs expérimentations en
cours sur le traitement de la
sonorisation
du nom des stations pour les lignes qui
sont équipées de vieux train qui
justement ne donnent pas le le le nom
des station donc il y a plusieurs
plusieurs expérimentations qui sont
lancées en parallèle sur sur le
sujet et puis je voudrais aussi mettre
en valeur l'application tradivia qu'on a
lancé maintenant il y a quelques mois en
cours de de déploiement sur le réseau
qui est une application sur tablette qui
permet non
seulement de faire de la traduction
instantanée dans en 17 langues donc qui
permettra d'accompagner très
qualitativement l'accueil des touristes
étrangers non seulement pour les jeux
mais également en
héritage après les jeux mais cette
solution permet aussi de faire de la
retranscription et donc a également euh
un effet positif sur les le le
traitement des handicap visuel auditif
je me permets juste pour finir deinister
sur l'aspect humain et sur les aspects
formation qui ont été très justement
rappelés aussi par mon collègue de la
SNCF et qui donc concerne évidemment
aussi c le traitement de de ces
handicaps
là la formation globalement permet aussi
modestement à notre niveau RATP
contribuer à l'évolution des mentalités
de de la société sur la prise en
charge des personnes en situation de
handicap
merci beaucoup si vous ne souhaitez pas
apporter d'éléments nouveaux il y a
Monsieur Adam qui voulait reposer une
question je vous en prie chers collègue
je voulais simplement reposer la même
question parce que j'ai eu une réponse
sur la partie tarification des navettes
mais sur la partie distorsion de
concurrence entre VTC et taxi vous
n'avez pas répondu pourquoi on n pas eu
la même logique avec les VTC de d'aide à
l'acquisition de véhicules adapté au
personnel mobilité réduite et sur
l'accessibilité des sites pour les taxis
vous avez répondu mais pas sur la partie
VTC j'imagine que pour navette on
considère que c'est traité mais pour les
VTC est-ce qu'ils auront le même accès
que les taxis au plus près des sites
parce que moi je je je ne suis je ne
sais pas expliquer aux acteurs du
transport public particulier de de de de
passagers que ils n'ont pas le même
traitement qu'il soit un taxi ou un
VTC monsieur
bon alors merci de de reposer votre
question euh effectivement le
la question elle elle elle s'est posée
pourquoi on a finalement Axès le
dispositif sur sur les taxis alors
d'abord pour dire que c'est un
dispositif expérimental pour 5 ans les
les licences délivrées aux personnes
morales en particulier qui a fait
l'objet de euh d'un article de loi pour
être pour être rendu possible et donc il
sera évalué en tant que tel pourquoi
cbler sur les taxis c'est que on a
justement euh des outils de de contrôle
sur l'activité des taxis et l'efficacité
du dispositif qui sont qui sont
disponibles pour voir si effectivement à
la fin quand on fera le bilan de cette
expérimentation ce sont bien des courses
à destination des personnes en situation
de handicap qui ont été euh qui ont été
faites finalement et si le le dispositif
est efficace c'est plus difficile de le
faire sur le sur les courses de VTC euh
donc c'est me semble-t-il pour ça que le
dispositif a été imaginé pour pour les
flottes de de taxi initialement ensuite
sur les accès et les déposes
euh il y a deux deux réponses à apporter
sur les accès les taxis peuvent circuler
sur les voies réservées c'est pas le cas
des des VTC euh en revanche sur la
dépose des personnes en situation de
handicap on travail pour que les lieux
de déposeuse taxi et VTC soient de la
même manière au plus proche des sites de
compétition
évidemment merci beaucoup je crois qu'il
n'y a plus de question donc à Maxime
minot pour une petite intervention
monsieur le co-président du groupe de
travail merci madame la Présidente oui
je me permets de reprendre la parole
puisqu'on n pas abordé un sujet c'est
notamment sur les forces de sécurité qui
auront accès en tout cas dans le cadre
de leur fonction un passe Navigo pour
pouvoir se rendre sur les sites dans
lesquels ils vont exercer le leur leur
mission en revanche il a été relevé
durant nos auditions que hors temps de
travail ils n'auront pas la possibilité
en tout cas leur passe Navigo ne sera
plus en validité donc est-ce que on peut
peut-être prévoir d'étendre ce Pass
nabigo puisqu'ils sont déjà d'ors et
déjà détenteurs euh leur permettre de
pouvoir circuler librement euh dans les
transports en en commun même quand ils
sont pas en
fonction merci monsieur le député qui
souhaite répondou juste pour vous dire
que effectivement des des échanges sont
en cours entre Île-de France mobilité et
la préfecture de police pour régler
toutes ces questions bon monsieur le
co-président est-ce que vous êtes
rassuré
merci voilà en tout cas moi je
souhaitais remercier tous les acteurs de
la mobilité qui se sont déplacés ce
matin et qui ont bien voulu vous être
prêté au jeu des questions-réponses et
merci pour la la qualité des réponses
que vous avez pu apporter et mais qui
était dû aussi à la qualité des
questions
qui vous ont été posé donc
c ces commissions réunies ces deux
commissions ont vraiment été très
profitable
ou
monsieur oui là on était vraiment à la
conclusion ah
ben merci elle est très simple ce
vendredi 26 juillet c'est ouverture sur
des
JO ce vendredi sera un chassé croisé
c'est une journée de vacanciers donc
avec ces 600000 spectateurs qui vont
être acheminés au au Go tous dirigés
vers les transports en commun et les
autoroutes avez-vous penser à se chasser
croiser ce jour de
ensuite je une deuxième question c'est
sur le bilan carbone on en a pas parlé
alors si on pouvait en connaître un
petit peu plus je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député pour la
première question il avait déjà été
répondu en partie par
nos les les différentes personnes qui
sont intervenues donc si vous pouvez
répondre rapidement si vous le souhaitez
sur notamment le bilan carbone alors
nous nous n'avons pas fait
particulièrement de de bilan carbone des
Jeux Olympiques en revanche Paris 2024
est tenu de de faire un bilan carbone
qui prendra évidemment en compte
l'ensemble des activités le transport
sera un un un des champs qui sera pris
en compte dans dans ce bilan
oui simplement pour dire que au-delà du
du bilan carbone chiffré en tant que tel
la promesse en Île-de-France elle est
très claire c'est 100 % des spectateurs
en transport en commun ou en modes
actifs et donc en mode de transport
décarboné donc voilà après il faudra le
quantifier c'est effectivement Paris
2024 qui qui organise ce ce bilan
carbone à l'échelle de l'organisation de
l'événement merci donc je vais à nouveau
vous remercier et laisser la parole au
président de la commission du
développement durable et de
l'aménagement du territoire qui a une
une annonce importante à faire auprès de
ses commissaires je sais pas si elle est
importante mais avant de faire cette
annonce à mon tour de vous remercier et
remercier aussi la la présidente de la
commission des affaires culturelles et
de l'éducation parce que je pense que
nous avons intérêt à travailler main
dans la main entre commissions sur des
sujets aussi importants donc un très
grand merci aux collègues et un très
grand merci à vous pour votre présence
et la pertinence des propos que vous
avez formulés nous en venons donc à un
sujet important aussi euh on va les
collègues de la ddat il va simplement
falloir rester puisque nous avons encore
quelques sujets à traiter donc ce que je
vous propose c'est que nous fassions une
suspension de séance et qu'on se
retrouve dans 5 minutes notamment pour
traiter les sujets de nomination et
d'article 88 à tout à l'heure chers
collègues